if black plays 26 and he does it I like
this you're giving up be seven happily
if you get things like procreate I
thought no stuff brookie some white kind
of trap the queen again oh my god firuze
you literally just did one of those like
you've gotta be oh my gosh
the second time trapped is old queen
second time oh my gosh if you're just
joining us in epic fashion in the five
minute segment way he was getting
outplayed and swindled his way to a
victory by trapping all the arrests
Queen deja vu all over again
thank you Yogi Berra and welcome
everybody to the Junior speech has
championship and Robert looking as
juniors ever and those dapper Dapper
p.m. NT pajamas I assume pajamas was
gonna say we're you're waking up at the
crack of noon on the East Coast over
there so hopefully they're sure not
pajamas you know it's already been a
long weekend and I'm just getting
started with you well this is gonna be a
fun show for those who don't already
feel that vibe but Robert and I don't
need to do much you know why because
these are arguably two of the most
anticipated players and this matchup
here is in many people's eyes for the
championship I think Geoffrey Jean might
have something to say about that Robert
before before it's all said and done but
let's bring up the bracket to remind
everybody of where we're at in Robert
I'm gonna let you take it away just tell
everybody how how excited you are for
the one seat Wei Yi a man who played in
the main speeches championship last year
is now taking on the young upstart who
by the way if you didn't get the memo on
social media ali reza firoozeh just
crossed 2,700 yesterday we are excited
for this Robert go and by yesterday you
mean today you're a hundred percent
right and Holly Raisa firoozeh has to be
the favorite I mean we looked through
the bracket where firuzan dominated Sam
seven I thought those one of the
toughest matchups in the entire field
because seven himself is something like
twenty six seventy really strong plays
in the chest comm server so firoozeh
against way e way he's an excellent
player Ben
750 was one the youngest players
speaking across the 2700 to do so but no
matter who wins this game match they're
gonna have a really tough final against
Geoffrey Zhang who is well 2700 himself
been playing excellent speed chess on
this server and well he had a very close
match of his bedroom Glenora so I have
to think that if version is to win he is
still the favorite against the American
Jeffrey Zhang well obviously we will
deal with that matchup when we get there
but I feel like the the Chinese might
have something to say about that today
and one of the things I know about how
wait ye feels going into this matchup is
that he feels like an underdog way he
feels like he does have much more to
prove in this particular format in this
P chess for men something about a 27 40
formerly north of 20 750 super
Grandmaster if that's how we define them
these days
feels about being an underdog it just
tells me that maybe firoozeh has a
little bit more of a fight ahead of him
than some might realize but okay we're
gonna see what the chess moves tell us
here in just a few moments for now let's
remind the few maybe newbies we have in
the chat of what this is it's the
juniors features Championship presented
by chess ked it's three hours of
awesomesauce five one three one one one
the one second increment ensures that
the chess board ultimately does the
talking no matter how fast it gets the
winner of this moves on into the main
SCC which Robin and I will begin
coverage at some point here in August so
out of the frying pan into the fire as
far as high-level chess goes and as we
said it's a 16 player bracket of the
world's best juniors and in the semi
finals we had four of the top five
juniors in there and right now we've got
the the last semi-final remaining what
are they playing for in addition to the
qualification spot a lot of cash money
homie enough to buy Robert a new
wardrobe maybe some updated Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle shirts right is that
what you would do is that what you would
do with 10 grand if you took it all home
I don't know I'd probably buy something
that would silence you or at least give
me silencing headphones noise-cancelling
headphones that's probably a good idea
hey they they do make those but you you
know for me the Bose Bose ear most might
not be enough I earmuff my kids around
the house all the time hey can you hear
Muffet for me I'm gonna call with akaru
moving in a verb that's that's great
that's not
let's let's talk a little bit about the
matchup here now of course there's a lot
of discussion that goes into how the
human beings all of us feel about this
but the stats the stats also tend to
lean ferocious way obviously they always
look a little bit lopsided I feel like
when you start reviewing at time control
by time control and you say well maybe a
game favorite in five one maybe a game
favorite in three one and in bullet yeah
I mean it's hard to not see him as maybe
even the heavy favorite there so I would
argue if way he doesn't have a game or
two lead heading into bullet then for
sure those seem accurate but what are
your thoughts looking at the predictions
and how you see these guys playing today
yeah I think that fruga has to be the
favorite he is the better bullet player
and that often tells the tale because as
you just said Danny Way is within let's
say one or two points that's a he's
ahead by two points I still think that
firs is the favorite and I also want to
point out that in their two matches
Perugia has been very dominant as I
mentioned against play like Sam 7
whereas what he did impress me in his
last matchup but I still have to give
the nod to Perugia 73% in his favor it
sounds like a lot when you're playing a
twenty seven forty ish player but I
think that's pretty accurate because if
Rouge is bullet prowess oli Reza coming
to us live is he DJ's from the small
kitchenette of his suite and Turkey and
Wei Yi is staying up staying up past his
bedtime we actually jokes aside about
where these players are across the world
we really appreciate it we know that Wei
Yi is actually coming to us at about
just after 10 p.m. right now in China
and he has a serious tournament game
tomorrow so this is this is when we are
able to make this matchup happen and
these two guys are pretty pumped so
gonna give a shout out here to the chat
for the first time we've got people a
lot of firoozeh emotes a lot of perugia
head emotes not a lot of way Yi hoping
we've got a few wayy fans there but you
know when we replay these matches and we
found this out during the protesting
when we do rebroadcast on our Channel
Robert we get a lot of of our of our
Chinese viewership in the in the off
hours at time so we know he's got a fan
base there that tunes in and the
question is whether a lot of them are
here right now I'm I'm calling for that
Wei Yi Fatheads support but doesn't like
we're getting any emotes there no no big
heads coming
alright hey that's okay
well the the games will be getting
started here soon I I don't know what
else to talk about is the semi-finals
we're playing we're nearing in on the
championship if you're if you're tuning
in to us from the grand chest or
coverage we covered that yesterday with
Mont Hamilton and we appreciate you
going back and forth between this and
the grand chest tour this morning but
this is this is really I think with what
Sunday's big chess event is right here
this is especially because of the
players we have yeah absolutely and you
have to know and understand it both
determined where this isn't just a joke
for either of them and it's not just the
prize money the chance to play on the
speed chess championship it's very
serious competitors in the upper echelon
chess they want to beat every point put
in front of them and they're certainly
taking this much serious and only Reza
beats most of the ponents in front of
him these days and again I mentioned
that for those of you that have already
been here there's 1,700 of you that have
been here a few moments ago I mentioned
that Ali Reza just crossed 2,700 it was
yesterday for me could have been because
I was listening to the Beatles
soundtrack after seeing the movie
yesterday by the way phenomenal have you
seen it I have not seen it okay so you
asked me if I seen the Lion King that's
we're gonna talk about that later but
all the reservoirs you just crossed
2,700 and that brings up our daily
question to get things started where we
have to ask everybody what defines a
super team these days is Olly Reza
firoozeh
officially at 2,700 now that he crossed
or is super GM because of the way the
ratings have headed Robert a little
closer to twenty seven thirty or even
twenty seven fifty we're gonna ask
everybody to get involved used to
hashtag speech s let us know your
thoughts Rob and I are about to dive in
here to the action but that's our daily
question congratulations again to all
the resume in the 2,700 Club and we'd
love to know your thoughts on what truly
defines the super team these days yeah
that's a really tough question I'm gonna
ponder it while I ponder these moves and
I see Danny you're gonna love the
opening that we have here I know that's
for sure what did you say why do you
always have to bring it back to that one
conflict we had that late night in the
hotel room well because you insulted my
clothes Sicilian and I said that
so that you're closed this morning
that's what you get for wearing a
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle shirt but I
did insult your clothes Sicilian why is
the last time your way he is playing it
so super I am so jokes aside the closest
Cillian especially in blitz can be a
very dangerous weapon White's got the
pawn structure building up for f4 and f5
but look at firuze you've taken the
flexible approach Robert this is this is
very modern
esque in terms of how black approaches
it right you've got the early rook b8
the early a6 the early 90 for preparing
b5 but not even committing the King to
the King side where white would get an
attack these are the kind of things that
give former rehab close Sicilian players
nightmares right yeah absolutely and
this age for push is already on board
and what white wants to do exactly 91
pawn c3 that's what is nice and c1
because we go pawn to c3 you don't want
the next chopper to b3 with the fork and
look at this F takes G 3d in because
black went full-on ahead on the Kings
side with a 2x4 but you haven't Castle
so if way you can get his pieces
coordinated and move those Knights off
the first rank and plague rook F to rook
a to f1 then he may build to launch some
pressure against the f7 pawn of course
that's very far off considering where
his pieces are placed but I like blacks
position on being honest yeah I don't
think that what you got what you've won
none of this d4 is very far off and
doesn't need to cast I'm also just
looking at the clock look how fast
ferruginous played and something tells
me that okay either this is this is full
on you know he knows feel very confident
terms of what he's prepared in these
lines or or maybe even expected the way
you might go for something like this so
the the variation isn't really anything
special I think I think d4 will problem
it by CD and then Bishop c4 here you
don't want to allow the d5 for key mode
obviously
Bishop c4 right away probably run ran
into d c5 so yeah he takes first I'm
expecting Bishop c4 now but what do you
think is this Moneda firuze you just
feel super comfortable in this line or
is wayyy
gonna say alright well I tried I tried
to see if you'd be ready for this and
I'm not going to be going back to this
very very many more times yeah I don't
think he's gonna go back
it's too much and I was wondering
actually that last moment night 85 was
gonna be played seven bishops II for it
let's analyze that you know the reason
why is you have 93 and 94 is dual
forking threats so you know after 95 d5
happened you could just put Knight to c4
and take on e3 something like that but
well I still like his position here
anyway and he's doing this I could get
wild in some positions if you take e3
and white take C 6 and maybe f7 so maybe
he decided I mean I don't know maybe he
decided hey I'm not even not even worth
that risk but okay so here firoozeh ends
up winning the exchange but way he's
gonna get some compensation one of the
things that worries me about this
position for Purusha Robert is that the
Knights coming to g4 and suddenly a
knight that kind of seemed like a donkey
for the last 10 moves might actually
come to life over here on the f6 square
ya know that Knight wants to rush right
to g4 and as you sit into f6 and then
we're gonna for one perfectly placed a
pressure on f7 as well so things are
looking up for we considering how the
opening didn't really feel like it was
going his way and May first took one
misstep and now it's gonna be easier for
way to handle this because the exchange
sac freed up the position the black king
is still in the center and as you
rightly point out Danny Knight g4 such
an annoying threat and I'm not yet sure
how to deal with it because of this
Bishop stare down on the bag so I think
that right now if you are firoozeh he's
taking his time but you have to figure
out am I actually going to Castle in
this game or am I gonna commit my king
to the center and say like well maybe
like you confront wheats I don't see it
we dig before the fact that all the
residents of time there was I think
suggestive of how he felt about that
little win of the exchange right maybe
something he wishes he could have back
this is this is where the closest
Cillian player in you right come on
admit though those old embers those old
embers still burn don't they they do an
IG they are burning inside what there
was nothing to think about for me in 494
it's just the oh yeah I don't know why
he even paused right make it happen
Cap'n he's gotta go King ups I don't see
another king of 7 but oh I want white
now g4 to follow
I mean it looks amazing this looks
fantastic for weight ye you can even
take on f5 immediately and just are the
night takes of five I guess mine of six
but you're not wrong cuz I mean the
attacker gets so wild with the bishop
coming in on light squares like h5 okay
g4 just feels like the move you play
instantly yeah right there I would only
check if there's like a queen Trey with
Queen b6 there's no way for black to
really deal with my threats or 1996-97
go to g5 e six nine eight seven dual
threat of Queen f6 and Knight g5 yeah
they're much fun we're gonna have today
this is gonna be a great match I'm so
excited for this this is so good good
night g5 v e6 but one of the issues in
the position like this and it sounds a
good joke when someone says it is we
need too many good options is actually
quite easy to go wrong right that's
being the perfectionist and you're like
okay you got that Queen f6 check first
or ePHI first I put mine own six all
right
is that more even do I take f5 here if
Knight takes I'd have g4 in at pawn
takes then Queen f6 and rook e1 is
bananas right exactly so I white as
white as a million ways to approach this
now I eat six f5 looks pretty good but
after GTA 5 I'm worried that I'm I
actually still like g4 now okay use
going I'm more pointing out that like
what is blacks next move so if you a g4
I think black will FX mean b5 and like
try try some kind of Queen b6 check sir
he goes for this ok he's freeing up the
f6 square so quaint e7 is not on the
agenda everybody
f6 is a threat obviously taking e4 would
be frowned upon in most regions after
it's something like rook up 7 or even
Knight f6 and other mates you know this
looks super rough actually it looks like
he may have found the best approach
given that he had many many ways to win
yeah the problem is your king is nowhere
to run to because if you got a Queen b6
checked and then King d8 they're still
just Knight f6 coming in these seven
score so loose
9 f6 came g8 97 you can win back
material you can also
little tickle right Knight f6 if you
just want to gain some time so
ultimately white should still win this
you have to say that okay from a
practical point of view if you're all
arrested you're like well leaves I
didn't get mated right and there aren't
you you know you can envision the
Queen's getting traded off there will be
some outside shots to hold a position
like this but I don't see how the
Queen's are getting trailed exactly rook
takes a five was it another free pawn
king each one the Kings it's perfectly
safe there the rook can always drop back
to f1 this looks just it should be a
matter of a matter of a matter of time
and I'm sitting here in my head
wondering where did all the rest go
wrong I think you and I both felt good
about his position as black and that
closest iliyan so I I just think that he
over or underestimated White's attack by
taking that exchange on f1 right yeah
that was not the exchange that you
really want to take and that's what
happened he went through c4 and then
Knight d4
I was thinking 1985 yeah no you were
right I I suggested Bishop c4 kind of
instinctively but I think you were I
think you were totally right and that
gives your closest Tilly an experience a
nod right yeah I understand how a bad
position can turn very quickly into a
good you're self-deprecating that's my
job that's my job okay and it's my job
to make fun of you II don't even you
know you don't need to acknowledge that
you ever had bad positions you know I'm
always coming for your jobs all right
okay now now the only worry White has
here is that d5 could be vulnerable so
you can't just play things like Bishop a
story but okay you're a wizard Harry
make it happen right I mean how do you
stop the HP pawn if you're Ferruccio
note that the Queen on c5 is is frozen
to the d6 pawn here which okay that's
that's enough of an Elsa problem that
all the residents is to let it go move
on and and guess what we have you got a
smile out of me which is actually we we
have a 1 Oh Victor now one of the
storylines coming into this match we've
seen her car Nakamura talked about it a
few times when he when he's been here
with us and and usually actively
involved in the chat and it's something
that you and I have wondered about how
we'll all you residue if he has ever put
on tilt right I think there's a reason
why so many people see him as a favorite
right thanks Captain Obvious because of
what we know about him not just as a
strong player over the board and we see
his player profile card there but also
what we know about him on chess not calm
that we know how good he is but how will
he deal with Mike throw it out there
what if what if way he takes a two three
point lead into the next into the next
segment right how does that tilt tilt
can be a real thing no matter who you
are and I think that'll be the storyline
we have to follow but speaking of
storylines let's remind everybody who
these guys are again he's only 16 he
just crossed 2,700 his interests are
fancy tech his strength his mouth speed
his weaknesses frustration so he's
openly acknowledging Robert that tilt is
a problem right the first step toward a
cure is acknowledging you have a problem
let's get to know wayyy a little bit
talk about the the Chinese here who is
our oldest maybe strongest junior but
he's also the number one junior in the
world he talks about how confidence is
very important in chess and so he think
I kind of made fun of this quote last
time and saying he thinks that winning
is a good idea and I said I think so too
but I think it really is important that
what he's saying is you know when you
get you know on a roll and you're
winning it can lead to more wins right
the the tipping point can be exponential
if you feel confident so I think he's
also talking to himself he knows how
much better he plays when he's confident
Robert what are you read between the
lines from that quote by Wei Yi yeah I
think he's just making a joke really and
having struggles psychologically
mentally well winning is a good way of
curing them especially for a chess
player but he's been not winning lately
he has lost 10 rating points throughout
this Chinese chess Li which is a very
difficult League so I'm not criticizing
in that regard he lost of the white
piece against Russia report I saw that
game the other day
so it seems like in his last few rounds
of chess it hasn't been going his way
but here in this jsut see I don't think
he's ever been behind way yep Bart
smarter chess stats are correct way he
has never been trailing in a JSC's he
matched right now he's up one game and I
think this pretty critical moment
because look at the d5 pawn look at that
b7 pawn how are you going to defend both
of those and the question I don't think
has a very easy answer because if you
take Knight takes e5 that might be the
way to go and give Y
some double pawns to worry about nicely
is on to worry about but you can also
very quickly see something happening
from Knight takes d5 let's say I take
with Bishop on e5 we trade bishops on
that actually probably you take it upon
you I would go day with the pawn yeah
but let's analyze this actually to see
so you're talking about Knight takes e5
ie takes black still has problems with
both of these guys I think the only
maybe potential form of compensation are
our main borders is still the last game
right now the only potential form of
compensation here might be that the the
C pawn is weak but the thing is right
now B and D pawns are hanging so you can
probably get a rook d1 type of maneuver
and quite fast to try right with C or E
4 but I would take right now in d5 the
e6 is black
so they actually go for the line you
talked about but end up taking with the
bishop and now that was partly why I
assumed that he might take with the D
pawn instead but uh but okay so now I
feel like what he's gonna find a way to
get some of his material back here and
you know probably gonna be an edge for
ollie Reza as they convert into the
endgame but how does white now deal with
E 5 and C 3 comparing them directly to
d5 and b7 I don't see any easy here it
looks to me like Black has found his way
out of this because if you play like
Queen takes d5 I think black can't even
consider movie 6 that's a weird move to
make giving up loops the Queen since so
many of whites pawns are falling I think
it's a possibility I don't really want
to take on c3 that badly right now
because after Queen takes c3 I was
looking down at move like rook to c1
first and that we gated tempo I'll run
through my Brooke on c7 and it's a very
important thing to keep in mind because
if you can take all the pawns when
you're giving black pawns to capture
right back but even in a temple move
with rook c1 first cuz II five is not
under attack that could be a very useful
tempo as the game continues well and
that's it's a good point to highlight as
he opens the possibility of a to rook
for Queen transition because if we do
head to an endgame what Roberts
mentioning there about gaining Tempe
if everything's gonna get traded anyway
the person that maybe gets the Tempe and
ends up with control over the open files
gets the seventh rank right gets
initiative on whatever the remaining
weaknesses are so I think a lot of times
these transitions are messed up by
players just assuming it's gonna be a
big trade fest without actually
anticipating who ends up in that endgame
with the first rook on the seventh rank
or the person who can really target
things so inadvertent teaching moment by
Robert has b6 is played
I don't think faroush it goes for the
two rooks for the Queen right now I'm
just probably trying to calculate how to
deal with pawns and he ends up defining
defining that problem with with a
retreat of the Queen to e3 which would
be interesting right I assume black is
gonna put a rook on da here you might
you might play a book to c8 first
because it is it is hanging yeah no I
was just I was highlighting just that on
the board and thinking that if Black
gets that whites up a pawn but black is
unwinding here yeah for sure because you
as white you're gonna be tied down let's
rook F to c1 look how awkward your rooks
are like rook FD 8 here you know Queen
e3 as you mentioned Danny then black
even considers like Queen c5 oh yeah we
ins because e 5 is weak I'll get my rope
to d2 if you trade Queens and looks like
black is just has really let's analyze
that to show that because I think it's
instructive again to see that if Rick
FDA 23 Queen c5 it's kind of what I was
just highlighting previously that yes
white did get the pawn here but this is
an in-game transition where who has
control of the open file who's gonna get
the first threats right 'if I've is
immediately under the gun so Queen e3
was played as we can see in the live
position and I'm and I'm curious how way
you will approach this if he plays Queen
c5 but also Robert if you look at the
live position and we keep analyzing it
the fact that this bishop is kind of
spying awkward squares makes it
difficult the Queen on e3 okay ended up
going for Queen c5 but so so again like
this is just kind of an awkward
transition here by Olly Reza into a
position where waggy down a pawn but may
be the one playing for the win
yeah I would be black here but that one
outside with to downsize one is that you
are down upon and if you don't win it
back or win it back in the correct way
then all of a sudden whites advantage
can become real I think but it's not
better here but what I mean by that is
as time goes on you get frustrated
you're down 30 to 40 seconds on the
clock right now right this how advantage
is pretty great for all erase' that can
start making you nervous if I don't get
my palm back now am I ever gonna get it
back and some of King g7 for example I'm
not saying it's a bad move but what is
the intention oh maybe that I'm putting
my king up more sabe any Queen h6 I can
get consider playing for h6 maybe g5
later right now I don't want to allow
pawn to a5 is black so I my queen on a5
threatening c3 pawn yeah there it is Wow
I mean wait yeah just I'm speaking it
he's speaking to me I don't know how
that works but you are yours you're like
a way Yi Whisperer right now it's
totally unintentional you're whispering
shout-out to our sub they're celibate
though I know that guy that's because
he's subscribed for 35 months that's how
I know that guy okay well wait you plays
Queen a5 I like blacks position you can
play Bishop e6 here the C 4 square is
open Yeah right I was gonna say h4 h5 h6
is always an idea for white but if you
go h4 black might just play h5 what are
you doing Casey forest play there can
also be Brook to c5 here which not only
hits a 5 maybe prepares to double rooks
on the C file at some point he's gonna
go c5 with Bishop e6 first she stops to
five I like that look at the clock right
I mean Olli Rosa was up more than a
minute that's kind of dwindling away so
this is a this is a technique clinic my
way yeah right now it is I mean the the
the more experienced player as far as
chess goes right the the higher rated
player the older player by almost four
almost five years of age that's where
way he's gonna have his potential
advantage in this match is in these
blitz in these slower portions
right where he can really really show
chest strength before it becomes a
bullet fest I guess so
you don't have a dude danny is I would
try to liquidate before it got too ugly
I would Bishop d5 here and the reason
why I say that is by playing Bishop b5
we start trading off pieces and I could
see an endgame appearing where White's
down a pawn at some Brook end game where
it's theoretically it should hold it but
I don't Lee you could spend all your
time here as white trying to figure it
out and with this mission reinforcements
immediately by roof d4 and I know I was
gonna say I'd like Bishop III on your
idea cuz you're saying I got even care
about c4 if I put the bishop on d3 maybe
I get an attack but wayy just
confidently playing rook d4 immediately
and look at the clock it's just okay
Queens now between takes e5 is good I
think that might even be best don't even
take the c4 pawn oh you didn't try to
trick him Queen takes e5 Sam Bishop
takes g6 thing so if you take on e3 I
take with the F pawn and attack your
rook on D right but even there black
takes c4 and who's better in that
endgame right I mean probably but black
for sure is better there but I think you
know that would be the best possible
situation with some okay he's going for
it
okay Bishop d5 is always that we're
gonna get trapped no no you can trade
and go to d2 okay so that that's the
idea there but g4 actually it's a Kia
and c4 so right that works and now the
trade on e6 won't be as good for white
because F shakes and the c4 pawn falls
in all these lines so again for those of
you who who said anybody picking against
all the rest was crazy this is this is
what we were waiting for is is a the one
seed in the bracket can can way Yi show
that that it's still chess even if it is
online even if it is with a with a lot
of mouse speed mattering so alright we
may be in store for our time scramble
see if ye has the ability to convert
yeah I mean he's now the pawns very good
pawn because oh and just like that he
knows so taking a two-game lead I think
you just forgot about the clock the way
he reacted after losing on time was such
that he didn't even appear to be look in
the clock and he finds himself down to
Oh for the first time so Robert I mean
this was the storyline that had been
forced out of what's going to happen
here
what's gonna happen with with ali reza
really being under the gun against a
super strong player here in the long
blitz time patrols remember increment is
not something these guys play very often
so for the fans who who you know are
just used to the time scannable being
decided by the mouth slip this is a
serious event where the increments going
to ensure that chess moves will at least
have a big part and who wins you know
and i and i think that this is this is
all the arises chance to prove himself
right now I'm shocked I know I can't
think of a time when bruza has lost on
time like that like just this isn't a
pure bullet game right with no increment
where he was on time in every single
game but he just didn't make a move and
then he looked like he was shocked that
he lost in time so that was really weird
for me and that's a very bad sign if you
are another eyes of rusev and because
right away he is an incredibly talented
strong player he's 27 27 in the live
ratings and he's been up to 27 50 and as
you said Danny that the age the maturity
the experience that way he has it could
come to his advantage in many of these
positions and throughout this match
Louis d65
a7 is hanging so it's gonna f3 first but
he gives up the bishop pair by taking on
that 3 so early and right now I'm
uncertain do you play G takes up 3 the
point is either G takes f 3 you're known
allowed on Knight takes d5 because you
clearly 3 the knight could take on clock
pitting the Queen on up through so right
now is an interesting moment for Wei Yi
and I'm the more he thinks the more okay
I just say the more likely I thought it
would be that he took the pawn but
instead he goes for this okay I went
Bishop on p3 it's a beautiful piece good
for you for having your netid me five
and kick it at any moment at four and
once I get at four I'm gonna try to like
a five and open the F file and spy on
the f7 square and you know way he is not
holding back his willingness to
challenge all heroes in the main lines
right so regardless of you know
sometimes how people have different
approaches to online matches how much of
their their high-level chess prep do
they use and like we said I think both
these guys want this way Yi wants to be
back in the main sec where he feels he
belongs right where he was invited to
play last year before we had the junior
speech has championship
so I think that I think we're gonna see
where you really try to go after all
heroes in these blitz time controls with
main line theory like this where he
again is kind of got the better out of
the opening you by the way notice that
it was all the reza who didn't go back
into the sicilian the close sicilian
which is what we had in Game one
remember so I'm curious about that right
even though we kind of felt good about
in position until that exchange sack so
we'll see how that plays out there's
white one h3 before playing f4 just to
stop Knight g4 maybe here but the
question for for white is how's he gonna
deal with the a 5-pound long-term earth
this Knight comes back to c6 maybe yeah
I like the move Bishop c2 because that
opens up f4 is a real possibility since
and a question I have in addition to how
to meet any 19-4 ideas is how about
Knight c4 as an option because that rook
on be a right now I'm not doing too much
but if I trade on the seat boy square my
work is staring right down at b2 and
that's he also loosened the e4 pawn
right the men in d2 is doing a good job
of protecting before but I think he'll
wait for white to play f4 before trying
to move a nice the ends up going back to
c6 I kind of liked your knight c4 move
let's analyze that real quick just to
show that maybe this could have happened
if nice c4 takes takes I liked your idea
b2 falling maybe threats of d5
I wonder what Dali Reza didn't like
about this transition here maybe he just
wanted to be greedy
he's like wanted to be greedy right upon
to pollen right yeah I've got the memo
and he's gonna go back to gathering up
the a5 fun but ok even if he wins it
regardless of the fact that it is blitz
it's I still think white has has an
attack meaning in a practical setting I
would be worried about f4 e 5 coming for
white anyway and then the fact that it's
blitz makes it maybe even more dangerous
for black so that's the risk if all the
residues all in and he goes for it on
the Queen side here gateway he plays
Knight of 3 there's threats of both
knight h4 Knight f5
hitting g7 there's threats of e5 there's
also threats of rook d1 hitting d6 and
you because you lose a 600 the
Rosaline's in there because he
committed to that a pond somebody made a
comment earlier that way ease camera is
frozen no that's just his resting chess
face he's just focused
it's called resting chess face you ever
had it Robert show us your resting chess
face yeah I have to be playing my RCF
you know I can't mine looks like I'm
blacking out but it's like this that's
my resting chess face all right once or
twice regardless of where you are thanks
for being here we love you and Chad
thanks for your appreciation and support
of these events and chess TV chat you
guys are getting jiggy with those emotes
they're the Flair that we've recently
brought you glad to see a lot of premium
members active over there and again
thank you to everybody for your support
shout out to all of our mods and
everybody who's here with us alright g6
is played here comes 4k to d1 I think I
like it
you know why you played g6 of course
first committee attacks the h7 but also
to allow that night to hit hop to h5
where it's defended so of course right
now the d6 blonde is under attack with
next but what about the d6 one because I
liked your point about the rook on a1
keeping the knight prisoned it's more
about the threat of a 5 right because of
the pin on the Queen I think because 94
could be played here but then e 5 is
probably still punched through and then
Knight h5 ok let's analyze right if
Knight e5 Knight h5 Queen moves if b2
Falls d6 Falls I actually no idea what's
going to happen here right feels like
there's mixed bag because you know I'm
giving up these things you mentioned but
maybe I can go Queen CH on a trade
Queens and say your B two pawns one more
than my d6 I don't know okay you goes
for v3 which is means we're not gonna
get the line I'm highlighting on the
analysis board but we did get the first
two moves predicted way you plays be
free all the resident has played not h5
but he's in one night 83 now he's intact
as bishop and say it's not under attack
anymore
you're never gonna trade my known a3
icon was about D force like that so I
think the move Knight a3 here is just
nice because the bishop rests go to d3
and it cuts off the defy like it like
Queen f6 Knight f4
I love through this position right now I
think many I think there
yeah you know a3 I like the way all the
residents play this I'm still
questioning in my head why way you
didn't go for e5 but I'm just gonna
buckle up and enjoy like everybody else
here because I wear the way you should
have gone for five or not it's in the
past right what do they say in the Lion
King Hakuna Matata exactly it means no
worries no worries don't focus on the
past let's try to play the presents but
but jokes aside I really think that
where you might have missed his chance
I'm liking all the roses unwinding the
f-4 square is now available for the
night on h5b files opening maybe all the
rest is about to strike back yeah here
comes that yep I like it you're gonna be
too and what is you know the same
initiative you had before work a warrant
by night see to winning one of the rooks
with a nice fork and I don't really see
that many good moves anymore for white
because blacks oh okay that's a good
move I would say I don't see any good
moves he plays Queen d7 oh no I don't
see oh there's one going T seven
actually I mean the fact that the
Queen's coming to a four that I talked
about a switcheroo right if we're
thinking the Queen was on g4 and you
want to play imaginary chess I'd love to
put my queen on a four right now
well that's one way to do it so maybe
this you know Seaport BC to be to idea
was a little too quick and if anything
is indicative again of the fact that
this is the longest time control where
the highest quality chess is usually
played in these segments although fun
fact for those wonder we evaluate all
everything that happens in these sec
historically with our cap score and of
course we're always evaluating with our
kind of advanced cheating anti fair play
detection stuff the strongest segment of
all time is actually a Nakamura segment
played in a 3-1 match and you know you
remember the match that was against
Robert Wright well I would say you know
was against fel so even though normally
5:1 is where we see the most highest
quality chess played by all these guys
so and and that's where Olli res is
gonna be challenged the most I think by
wayy and the slower the time control so
look at this way he's gotten himself
back in it
and for just time management has been
get add to it I'm sure he's very tired
from playing 13 games of chess in like 7
days or whatever it was but I'm worried
about him right now because he's right
now it's he's in bad shape with this
game it looked great for him now all of
a sudden c4 Falls the diner pieces
situation is actually quite nice from
black so I'm not sure if you take on
support right away or if there's some Oh
Bishop c4 Knight c3 c5 that's the tag
day if you take on CP with the Knight e5
has played a cut your queen off from the
Nancy breathe let me show it to the
bat-cave we go if Knight takes c3 e5
that's diss communication right and you
just win the night for free that's what
all the rest miss you could actually see
him sort of kind of mumbling on his lips
after Knight b5 Bishop c4 he was like he
gave himself a frustrated like dude come
on right that's an easy tactic but but
now he's gonna be down a piece and all
in on trying to justify an attack and
maybe he'll do it look at that move
Knight h3 f2 is falling so Bishop e2 e2
quickly and take take advantage of all
your pieces defending each war Judas he
gonna made him no Luke takes me to you
can just run the King to the Senate Rick
be to Russia from Jay King everyone yeah
just get the King out of Dodge right in
fact where calculates he's going for it
you scared me at the very least hey I'm
here for you if you get scared please
say no Ruchi one's coming next
yeah rook g1 it's actually not so simple
but if you switch sometimes
White had 5 seconds in black and 40 then
I would say black is a good chance at
the times they are just Wien takes d6 as
possible because on either
Queen f1 chair and I when Queen upon
King III if you take b5 okay if we take
off everything here and go into a rook
ending White has the winning chances
with the C pawn right so d4 dude is king
he's not a walkabout don't remind me at
king of the hill yeah I've been
sabotaging us in our match versus the
chess bras with those ridiculous
variants all I'm saying is when real
chess was played
okay that's what I'm saying Queen we see
to meet you looks good now you can even
play see 4 and then king b5 discovered
check runs away dude the c4 with King d5
would have been a nasty way to just walk
the King up the board don't tell John
Locke what he can't do right that King
has gone on a walkabout and loved a also
known as way e has taken a 300 lead in
this match yeah that would've been a
walk to remember you know that's Hey no
one goes Keanu Reeves on this show
unless it's me so take that back hey
Walter remember it doesn't have Keanu
Reeves it has Mandy Moore Walker rivers
oh no I'm thinking of what am I thinking
a walk in November what's the count of
reason somebody help me in chat here I
was a guy out I was doing Nicholas
Sparks so there you go
now we're going on first of all any time
Keanu Reeves walks he's cool if he
didn't know that you can see it on
Twitter so that he does give us walks to
remember on a regular basis but all
right Point Break great movie there you
uh let's get that guy a diamond
membership Burge eke out can someone
make a note just for mentioning Point
Break he gets in one month time in
membership we got it buddy cop in right
now that's that's the kind of show we're
running here today Point Break shout out
to my boy peace ways all right beginning
Point Break bruisers trying to use this
game to break to break I mean he's down
three oh he's got to stop the bleeding
yeah he's very quickly so he's taking a
new approach because the other games has
actually been down one time yeah all
them and right now he's just saying look
at your isolated pawn look at my rapid
development my rook can go to e1 my
bishop can go to h4 the g3 if need be
and this isolated pawn I say pawns are
really difficult to deal with especially
in blitz the especial ins a knight
blockaded my d4 you up late because you
always feel like there's some targets
Knight g4 is an option here who black
actually because 94 of 30 Queens you
make in your mission Bungie
I don't know if it's a good idea I like
that idea and he and nice eyes by the
way you spotted that that's right yeah
that's the guy the prime guy gets to I
have four of them so my eyes the one
left I mean hey you've got anyway so
Bishop Bishop on c5 is gonna fall after
hd4 and again possible way you miss the
shot like it for black just take on g4
after Bishop takes g5 right 92 to f3 you
can't Eve it so you can't play a fourth
at five I want it to play at four I
forgot he could just take it yeah okay
he goes there but black is gonna back up
the bishop and I guess from a practical
perspective at least I don't think all
heroes is that good of an actor I think
he did miss Knight g4 but you may be
right you may have just blundered into a
good position right because now the
domination of the night over the bishop
and this kind of iqp position upon g'bye
and if you take me into b7 you're
playing Knight f5 right if you should be
7 taken 6 like rook e1 rookie - ok this
is just the queen of 4 I like that move
right still the rook 81 is natural
response here rook 81 and if it's ok he
takes on g5 I think he has ideas of f4
and f5 he wants it bad a Franken Bishop
I call it and I agree with that and it
is frankly and not a good piece you know
what you might want its king of 2 and
rook to the H file ok a bad idea what
can black do here black might try h5
just open up that Bishop a little bit
and get the King some love but I think
just it if you trade the major pieces up
like Queen d1 from takes me eight rook
e1 like this
oh great you wanna be four is gonna
dominate this bishop for the rest of the
game and shout out to Diamond remember
the real Greco in the chess TV chat who
comes in with the expert analysis Robert
he says if firoozeh wants to win this
match he'll have to win some games
eventually
wow that is so shoutout that is unique
commentary that is that is some
high-quality stuff right there
Thank You diamond remember real Greco
all right Queen to d1 what does he want
is he it does he just want to trade and
then challenge the e-file or does he
want to come in with the Queen to b3 Oh
H five he's gonna make this nasty before
it's all said done and that's again of
the mark of a strong player he's not
just gonna let himself get grinded here
right way he's gonna try to mix it up
I'm expecting f6 here I like my version
done though because he's just
liquidating and saying look at this
Knight look at your Bishop on d7 your
Bishop is no future my knight has his
present which is the beautiful piece yep
I like white for sure
whoa rook e5 but I'm gonna I'm just
gonna challenge that from the
perspective that okay even though I
think we've liked white for a long time
here like what is he really getting as
far as pressure against the pawn in it
it usually trades if you get you and if
you get an endgame at some point if you
haven't put pressure on it your chances
of targeting the D pawn get less and
less the more pieces at least if there's
no major pieces I guess the big thing
you're gonna come back with is that even
the King and pawn ending has great
winning chances for white because of the
access this King might have in like a
knight versus Bishop King owns the dark
squares is that is that why you look at
this is just really having good
long-term chances for white yes
absolutely
so moving Knight C to charge straight
rooks on e5 right there its pawn on d5
and ask you what you can do bishop and
as you mentioned which is a very good
point but even in everything off the
board except for the nine be sure
they're still changing from white to run
the kings of d4
pressure by pawn and then try to make
progress your knight can go to either
square cuff and the bishop is just stuck
on the light color yeah it's a great
point
I answered might look at that I'm
thinking like Robert has more and more
we need more Danny from you know not
when it comes to the chest buddy we did
we know how good you are you just want
to read a king's recently by the way you
know I really didn't even you didn't
even reach you eat my tweet that had
Will Ferrell saying you're my boy I love
that by the way that was awesome thank
you
if Will Ferrel gifts from old school
aren't retweet above what is anymore I
don't have an answer to that I'm I'm
speechless
I think fruit is not gonna win this game
though and that's making me nervous for
him yeah he's down three Oh at some
point at this point I would argue even a
drawers got to be successful you know
the let's say as the real Greco might
say going down for Oh would be a bad
idea would be a bad match strategy so
firoozeh just needs to do something here
yeah but um you have to see what gage
Fireblade right that's actually
phenomenal point I mean we're we're
having a great time here but let's
analyze that actually the Queen h4 has a
lot more problems coming from luck in
fact now that you have two Trey but that
fixes the structure so again let's
highlight for everybody what the threat
was I moved like night c2 rook h5
suddenly the counter play is real so
ferocious hand was sort of forced but
that's a move that fixes black structure
now look for even Bishop e6 other moves
that okay while these pawns are targets
they are hanging this is not gonna be
just a clear walk in the park of a
dominant night versus a bad Bishop
anymore totally agree to make we e3 is
an idea to keep an eye on because the
text a five and a seven the same time so
there are some tactics here that way yes
I'm careful about but I agree with you
Danny so you will Queen C for now Knight
e3 Queen takes a chip Queen takes d5
check has to be like a Miss a first
thing that would come to my mind or in
just Knight 65 it's probably better to
keep the Queen's on the board I did all
this point traded Queens is just
liquidating too much but with this
position look at King see that sounds
like we making safely yeah yeah but your
King on G there aren't pieces over there
Queen is all the way over there on a2 so
vulnerable yeah if you get this Knight
to e7 don't step to the H file because
that may be the the last place you visit
some sort of mating yet I guess
nice and there's kept seven my knight
gets trapped pretty quickly yes if
ninety seven let's look at that
97 king of seven something okay he goes
to see seven but something like this
probably wouldn't have been a good idea
because there's no real threats for
white and everybody's frozen to guarding
each other so he goes to see seven
note that firoozeh has a bailout
Perpetual at any time probably with
something like Queen d8 Queen h4 yep so
gotta be a little careful here and goes
live the time situation plane maybe five
just play Knight d5 threat just threaten
things so you're dead me five Holly 396
checking p7 I love it you know then you
drink Queen D 896 check you that's the
key in it sort of a bullet match where
we're getting right now the bullet game
you should just play ideas that are not
paying anything but have a purpose and
here in the movie I was like king each
to or night to be five the reason I like
95 as well is Queen C for kind of annoys
me like like huge to Queen C for
threatening the 1917 Queen age 41 right
if 95 you're not saying Queen C for
right away right it's the four key mode
on d6 he aged - instead of Knight to d5
going for queen d8 instead he's
threatening Queenie eight check that's
his idea but the only way you might go
all-in on the chance at a perpetual here
targeting the geometry Queen age 7 but
again if you look at the clock Robert
something tells me that what you said is
right it's like ali reza is clearly off
his off his normal comfort zone being
down in a rare setting and a Blitzer
bullet match and he's he's almost trying
too hard right if I agree with you
Robert if in normal Holly Reza you
nobody would have done he would have
played 95 instantly Robert Hess has
gotten better at chess because now he
plays more instant and trusts his
instincts maybe you should give this
advice back to Olly Reza well I don't
really think he needs my advice in chest
because he is 2,700 but I'll try the
largest comeback victory in the jet now
the JSC C does not have as long a
history as the speech has championship
right this is our first year doing this
event for for only the world's top
youngsters but the biggest deficit ever
overcome successfully was two points now
we have seen four-point deficits
overcome to come back and tie the match
but the person who was winning still won
the
right so the biggest turnaround we've
fully seen is a two point deficit which
means already Olli Reza is up against
history here to do a bigger comeback
than what we've seen so far now
the biggest comeback ever in these
formats is actually four games we have
seen people be down for games and come
back and win in the the main speech s
championship format so so don't you know
don't get don't get too nervous here but
you should get excited we've got nearly
9500 of you right now if you're joining
us whether it's chess calm or twitches
homepage make sure you click that follow
button for the biggest events in chess
we love that you're here the chat is lit
at least I think it was I know maybe
it's not as lit but make it lit for us
chat like safely like don't go full
arson here but do some things to make it
fun one thing I'm noticing this is yep
totally a side note is look at ways
connection right to balls and that's
gotta be a concern for it going forward
because the last thing you want is when
you're up three games to lose a game by
fourth name because you disconnect and
we see that in other speech chess
championship matches so if you are wayy
you just better hope the internet stays
put but right now with the white pieces
here look at what he is doing he's
trying to go all into the attack I don't
know I'm gonna be honest with you I
don't love it because she takes b5 this
is one of those positions where whites
Center can collapse very quickly and
you're I don't know how real your attack
is I was saying it's like he's feeling
his opportunity to really strike here
again we've got a lot of viewers here
who may be surprised if you tuned in
thinking oh all the resident was
definitely the favorite you're gonna be
sticking around all 10,000 of you
because that may not be the case wayy is
showing and I think he's kind of sensing
up her like if he wins this game it
takes a four point lead
that's what he's trying to do he's
trying to be he's trying to go for the
most direct way for the kill whether
it's sound or not right he wants the
attack not he's not doing it right now
I'm actually worried about whites
position for my pure chess point of view
because look at the b-pawn if you played
you like b3 which obviously the
intention is not hang your pollen b2
there are going to be ideas what's 19 g4
and if your Bishop takes you 493 check
let's look at that let's analyze that
that
fantastic line if be free Robert has is
pointing out the brilliant point that d3
is vulnerable right will make it change
colors for you to really get the point
across Knight takes chief for will
deflect this Bishop and then Knight d3
check comes in followed by dangerous
things on f2 with the Queen something
like this Bob would be your uncle so
that's actually that's actually a
serious problem look at Wei Yi using his
clock here I think that points out that
he maybe just spotted this idea of
Robert okay so let me try to stop both
what if I play Queen c2 that guards v2
and guards d3 when it hangs g4 anyway
ocean anagen eyes errs oh my gosh sorry
I almost went oh I'm Jesus snaps there
but I actually way you all of a sudden
I'm being realizing that's why he's
spent a minute a half here because it's
like oh crap right can I say that in a
chest get sponsored stream he's like Oh
darkness Mertz
you should meet Suppan is hanging darker
smarts can we get a check on that I
think he doesn't okay very okay he does
so now he stopped the tactic why would
you spend a minute and 45 seconds on
that it feels like a really bad waste of
time because Bishop f6 is natural to get
rid of that Knight which is technically
for attacking g4 and you don't think
White's position is better because they
don't think it is but spending two
minutes the main down move which makes
sense and I you know like you you called
it right when he blew if we back up real
quick and analyze this if we on h4 you
called it that this was just super
suspect Queen b6 pointed it out and
white immediately has to part with the
bishop pair but like you're saying white
why take two minutes to just acknowledge
that you went wrong right yep now blacks
playing f6 opening the F file f2 looks
like a nice target keep still shout out
to my boy Teddy Coleman DJ G Ward's no
one can call me a clown like you baby
thanks I love how he doesn't think that
I know who he is
alright
h5 is played we'll see if we can justify
something on the H file but I'm with you
this could be this could be what the
people have been waiting for I like that
the be for square is now Blackstone the
taking the a to pawn spending a little
vulnerable the Queen can hop into D for
in the near future
I'm f6 and still an idea if you take on
g6 I might take with the F pawn
threatening your f to square
it's nothing real nice or cruiser in law
I love that again and the attack was
launched early but this it's nice when
chess principles still do the talking
right which is that as you said h4 was
kind of unsound whites King is gonna be
the one in more danger at the end of
this game all the residents about to get
surgical up in these dark squares right
queen d1 not a move you expect and I
don't know maybe he's about to go full
Karpov put a knight on b1 a bishop on f1
and undeveloped his pieces yeah several
of those people here would play with a
queen be one but that undeveloped thing
move looks very risky and i know i'm
i've been harping on this point Danny
but at any moment I want to play f6
and I know been finals has never put
okay yeah no I saw someone in chat
screaming for f6 earlier and it's a it's
a rare moment where Ben Feingold might
be wrong
yeah King f1 if I take on f2 with the
pontiff's I've been missing it's me so
f6 I want to take on g5 and make you one
of two that's my clearance I just want
it i I want it all and I'm right now he
does it for more Seles wallets brussels
enough the pliers and a blowtorch here
we go
that was a great reference I'm proud to
take on g5 ignore h7 ignore h7
absolutely ignore that be an umbrella
pawn and what we mean by that is if we
take on g5 and you take on h7 actually
protects the king hey if there's a
seven-year-old watching this and knows
that Marcellus walls reference that is a
parental problem that is not my problem
producer your seven-year-old has seen
Pulp Fiction all right I love it I love
it King and Jade here here we come
Marcellus is on the F file double rooks
rook up six and bring it I mean also
things like more work at four even
better
o three Danny that's also an option
right the ponte is do everything dude I
love it the dark squares
oh gee three would have been probably
lights out that would let's analyze that
I know we just we just left the Batcave
but we're back to at Queen III hitting
c3 and if rook c1 Queens
oh you you've resigned so all your eyes
that takes care of business but that's
nice because we'll move on to the next
game and I'll continue to analyze this
one here and show you that Robert Hess's
brilliant move this guy eats his
Wheaties Queen III would have hit the
night and if rook c1 queen g3 and the
rook is just either you let it be taken
or f2 is a bacon I guess right Kevin
Bacon which reminds me six degrees of
every test TV show comes back to the
mancave bake Robert Holly Reza has
struck we have a match a really good
game yeah that was that was the best
game start to finish so far yeah for
sure and right now he's on the white
side of the French so it has to be good
for white and the Queen went to be six
so in these variations black often plays
for Bishop to b5 to trade what is a very
bad piece typically in the French but if
you played Bishop to b5 now well white
can decide how exactly to continue you
can take out c5 and oats are opening the
position up and you're even getting rid
of the dark series electric or bishops
doesn't save black from some of the
bigger problems right the pawns on e5
taking up very important space in the
position there's a quick development now
take me on d3 I'll take with my queen
get another tempo move and look at that
- nice developed with the Queen
developed a headed development more
advanced to the center I read again we
can argue that Robert has his favorite
type of French is the French where you
trade off your bad bishop right so white
has the development lead but at least
blacks worst piece is gone
long-term advantages yep and I just
think these positions are so easy to
play for white yes you can put a 3 B 4
you can about the I want to get some
educational wisdom out of you here so
what is it about the transition in the
structure that tells us that white
should maybe play for because normally
in a French structure you want the
kingside right you've got the pawn chain
facing this area of the board and that's
where the pieces
want to play because that's where White
has space what is it about the structure
tells you maybe a 3 B 4 night a 4 is
something white should look for here
because I'm missing my light square
Bishop is white the attack and pressure
on the King sight isn't as easy to see
because normally white Tristan f4 f5
kind of right for just impression the h7
pawn here I'm not getting that because
black can just situate the pieces and
kind of clog the King side and soca we
have to play on both flanks and maybe
eight threes not the best idea but it
plays the knight a four it's trying to
heading to c5 right away I'm not certain
about this but I guess it's perfectly
viable but to summarize the main point
is it's not even so much the structure
it's more than what White's LightSquared
Bishop gone the chances of you
checkmating black are much less and so
looking at the full board a little bit
differently using your seat open C file
to c5 square that's kind of where your
Grandmaster has brain goes here yeah
like moving night at five I can play
that without a bishop on d3 and
seamlessly play it because you can't
take me on at five whereas with a
one d3 you I used to consider what
happens in the resulting pawn structure
with a Bishop d3 takes f5 I get double
bonds and things like that right that
would that would split the pawns if we
can use our imagination caps here right
trade off the bishop for that okay I
think that's I think that's useful to
know because I think sometimes we can be
married to ideas we've seen in pawn
structures and we're like well normally
I'm supposed to play on the Kings side
that's what I do in the French and here
recognizing the chance to change in
transition so what makes you nervous
about all the residence night a4 because
it looks like it surprised way he took
almost a minute on the clock there is
there some nineties d4 stuff happening
that's what I'm Knight takes d4
undermining the protection yeah it seems
overly ambitious especially because
black was behind in development when you
start allowing things like Bishop takes
e5 or 964 then black is going to develop
while trading while getting the King to
safety and everything seems to improve
yeah I'm not sure about Holly raises the
last couple of moves and I think I would
just play Knight to b3 here and yeah
just admit your mistake right
tell your tail between your legs and say
oops I'm not gonna try to justify the
night there and again everybody taking
b7 Queen to b6 and that Knight is
running out of running out of squares
okay well we definitely have a match if
you're just joining us Olly Reza
firoozeh was down 300 at one point in
this junior speeches Championship
semi-final he got a draw to stop the
bleeding and then won the very next game
so at this point we know we're
definitely in for a wild one as many
people see firuze as the favorite
the faster the time control gets so wayy
saying welcome to the the super GM club
kid right
g4 that is a move of your own heart oh I
think I have a g40 boat well let me find
it that is a Danny move for sure because
you know the idea is as I was mentioning
the nine that five can sit there but not
when there's a pawn on g4 that's right
that's how you get rid of a night out of
five you put your pawn on e4
protip you're welcome what is he for
night before Queen c2 if he goes 97 95
is he someone gonna take on c5 to the g4
pawn is somehow hanging with the Queen
on 84 we got to analyze that to the
Batcave we go if 97 95 I don't even know
that it works but we're gonna look at it
rook c5 pawn takes Knight c2 double
attack on the rook and the pawn on g4 is
is what Robert has once again just calm
bugs for vent g4 - G - I mean deploying
g4 looks a little bit of loose but
that's why I'm saying don't force things
for white you were right it's a good
move plan of course I will say the one
thing about this this position is even
if it seems like Wei Yi is unwinding I
look at the time I look at the body
language Ali Reza's success has started
in the last few games when he's kind of
sped up he's I'm almost double on the
clock here and his position is excellent
here because he trade off his Bishop
which is undeveloped he look at the
situation in terms of pieces black has a
rook on h8 Bishop run f8 that's at the
end of the world cuz ring g8 at some
moment I loved that movie h3 and I'm
actually gonna get that's prophylaxis
Holmes defend your weaknesses total
beautiful move because you're protecting
the g4
which can become under attack in any
moment now rook Jade isn't a temple move
and you're asking black commit to
something if you go Bishop g7
maybe I'll go Knight c5 and get your b7
yeah you don't want to give up the c5
square and if you were Bishop e7 then
I'll say all right so what do I do now
do I do another prophet lies on the King
to g2 and just continue to it but I was
gonna say if the bishop goes d7 you
could almost go slow play right Jamie
Foxx it on the h6 pawned just pick up
the pawn no well I don't worry about my
a to pawn at some point actually what I
can probably go take that okay yeah you
right now it's not take a bowl of course
cuz rook a 1 that's the that's the fact
Bishop e7 is played so now the Queen
can't just as we said slow Jamz so maybe
maybe way he's wiggling out of this what
where's the words to push through Ali
Reza has leaned in wait I think I don't
want my pawn hanging okay King G Jews
also probably good move but at some
point I don't want my pawn a to to being
they'll continue this what's blacks plan
right we talked about you know the
direct approach pushing forward clearly
for white but why not just take my time
play a3 play Queen c3 then move my
knight from b3 just take your time here
your queen right away but what about
Queen takes a - I just grabbed your pawn
yeah Queen takes a - was on the table
now because with the knife but not being
defended there was no rook a 1 so ok
he's playing aggressive here but is it
is it kind of caching and too soon on
the space and the control the whites had
I yeah I just don't permit it that's key
I think just take on c5 take on a 2 and
I understand that it might not be good
missed a bit risky because you're
putting your Queen so far away from your
king from a practical point of view it's
uh yeah giving up that Bishop is tough
his queen up for to f6 and things like
that look really annoying hmm yeah I
don't know why way he's thinking here
and this is a bit of the turnaround on
the match he's not it's not a connection
issue right he's rocking a four-bar
stable point of view over there in China
he takes what's he saying on Knight
takes b7 he's saying I'm gonna play
Knight to
before they behave that's sneaky ooh
he's gonna trade 90 xp7 rook b8 rook
takes c6 where it takes me seven and the
b2 pawn is the weakest point on the
board all right half of my doubt he goes
for it yep
I actually liked his turnaround for
black yeah I think blacks King is
actually quite safe there's no way to
get to it and 96 is the one idea but 96
doesn't feel like too much fascinating
that you just said blacks King is
actually totally safe over here right
despite the doubled open file
you know white has to be careful as well
because these pawns can't return Jim
Bishop to b4 okay I'm just playing
instinctively here maybe that's not the
best okay Queen B 1 is nice notice that
you can't challenge on the first rank
because b2 falls yeah and the Queen is
spying the light squares from this
backdoor diagonal yep and you can't go
91 or anything Bishop b4 as you point
out before so this is something tells me
we're still on on route for an ollie
Reza's victory to bring this to one game
just because of the clock but but I do
agree the chess is favored Wei Yi over
the last 15 moves I don't see impressive
my way to get out of this it's very
young I thought this position was really
tough I think that all ears are rushed
and I think he'll come to regret moves
like Knight to c5 things like that Queen
d2 you could have played this more
slowly by he but again if you look at
the clock this may be all he ever need
I'll bring the Knight to h3 now I think
doesn't work no I'm playing I wanted to
take on f7 but I didn't Queen h6 I see
but no I think this is the right
approach by ollie Reza
here comes h5 yeah the Brooklyn c2 is
hangs I couldn't even take any takes oh
my bad I got excited hey we all make
mistakes it's okay you know it's when
they're not my pieces I'm happy I know
how you treat other people's pieces okay
rook b3 he's gonna add the third rank in
the light skirts but again I look at the
clock and that's what I worry about when
he didn't take H worth I just go ahead
and steal that one Queenie - but there's
no squares
well Queen each five take gonna be seven
with check it's a mate right Queen h5 do
it he's doing it five Queen c2 it
doesn't matter Queen f7 and 96 would
have been
lights out not b7 saying take my bishop
your rook is that way e the heads-up
play is sacrificing h4 but then c2 falls
wowthat's and look at the time look at
the time we are closer to equal than
we've been all game I like that move
Queen the e2 because Queen d3 check is
an annoying threat with the Queen on b1
like that there's some discoveries so it
might just be a fizzle weird repetition
Queen h5 Queen e2 with what way he's got
his resting chess face on all the Reza
slightly more animated here Wow people
shouting for all the resident
I don't know that he sees an opportunity
to do so one more repeating of this and
we've got a draw and way he holds that
position Wow oMG xur snaps this time
direct shout-out to the emo go ahead and
use it while I remind you that upcoming
at chess comm we have a lot more events
not just the juniors features
championship but of course this week we
are also covering the grand chest tour
of Paris but right now we're gonna focus
on chest coms events I've got the title
Tuesday SCC qualifier the speech has
Championship qualifier as we transition
to the main event
and then we're covering the Sinquefield
Cup the two faces you will see most
often analyzing games like those of
Magnus Carlsen Levon Aronian Vichy and
on the whole field that'll be in st.
Louis will be me and Robert most of the
time and we're pretty pumped about the
Cinco Cup coverage first time we've
covered it directly here on chess calm
in a few years so mark your calendars
the protesting summer series is still
your chance to play alongside top
grandmasters so if you somehow just
discovered this chess channel boy are
you in for a treat on this easy like a
Sunday morning let's talk about the
grand chest or if we can remind
everybody that we're also covering Paris
we covered it yesterday right now we're
focused on the junior speeches champ
Jeff will be back at the Paris rapid and
blitz for the grand chest tour starting
tomorrow so make sure you are aware of
that and enjoin us join us tomorrow so
there you go there's our edge there's
our shed you know this event is a big
deal because even mr. dodgy chess was
spotted in the chat that guy's a grand
chest tour fanatic but he made the right
decision this Sunday Robert it's cuz
you're here no
because he want to hear you credit joke
at my expense go on anyway thank you to
everybody who's here all nearly 12,000
of you with us jokes aside we know this
is a big deal because of the players
that's Wei Yi and Olly Reza firoozeh
these two guys are giving us a treat
right now we're showing showing why he's
been 27:40 for a long time Robert with
his two-game lead yeah absolutely but I
like blacks position here and I think
that I would take on d4 once with the C
pawns and then pull my Bishop out like
to b7 and try to get rook to c8 and the
reason why I want that trade is because
let's say I played Bishop b7 first you
know I'm trying to get your for pawn and
you know that's pretty obvious to you
but if I claim you like pictures of b7
and you play pawn to d5 now the whole
Queen side is closed and black doesn't
reap the benefit of having an Oaks
you know send me open C files but see 64
is good to start with and then trying to
get the bishops like rook c8 next yeah
also there's there's a move like nice e5
if d5 is played right if people can
imagine that if Bishop d7 d5 right away
the knight doesn't have this square so
another reason why Roberts transition ok
h6 a little more prophylactic right ali
reza trying to stop whatever shenanigans
may come to the g5 square but this is
this is an interesting point of just
experience even though this is a common
structure for play grandmasters at this
level right they're both now above 2700
but there's a lot of decisions to be
made about the pawn structures right
robert you often highlight that whoever
controls the pawn tension often controls
the plan and is better and even even
players like this they are young as
strong as they are there's a lot to
consider like am I taking am i pushing
right do I want to maintain the tension
and that's why you see a lot of time
taken and these kind of critical middle
games right yeah absolutely right and I
do say that a lot of the pond tension
and right now there's a lot of tension
and it's in the center on this d4 square
and if white releases the tension with
pawn to d5 black is saying well where's
your next pawn break coming from them
happy but right but what the immediate
dread is Knight f5 in fact that's what
is I thought it was gonna be played now
cuz it was a pawn if you don't right
because the d4 pawn is particular the
night and now he's take on d4 but look
at the difference in the position then
is an f5 rather than on f3 and that just
huge advantage not
has a huge advantage but relatively
speaking that is clearly advantageous
for white because the night hop to
scores for there's sacrifices in the h6
squared you to consider and now what I
play d5 and close the center-right what
what happens when your opponent is
attacking you you want to play typically
in the center now you wouldn't get that
kind of play in the same way well I want
to go to the bat-cave real quick to show
your point because the the now analyzing
after after all the resin played h6 how
quickly way you play magic for him this
is a very common tactic everyone should
make note of that the Knights on these
squares like f5 are even stronger when
there's a pawn on h6 and the reason is
because there's never an opportunity for
black to play g6 without material
falling and so way you just super
quickly if you look at the time logs
pounces on h6 to improve the night as
Robert said now faroush is aware of that
he's now put the night on f8 he's trying
to get rid of that pony the
old-fashioned way by capturing it with a
bishop but I agree with you Robert and
it's just looking at the experience that
way he has here right to instantly play
this maneuver when we played h6 rather
than your suggestion of maybe taking d4
earlier yeah no I I think that h6 is one
of those slight inaccuracies that I love
your opponent to just gain a lot of
important space bishop gets it's saying
who has the dark square bishop only
white so I'm going to try to open that
and long diagonal if you ever take me on
d4 you're probably gonna crushed very
quickly because of that bishop
and now he plays Bishop b2 which points
out this is probably the best way to let
to allow this trait that's now happening
and the reason everybody is you wouldn't
want to play for example if I show you
wouldn't have wanted to play d5 and
close anymore you would do that if you
could keep your knight on f5 and and do
mating net things but when white is is
is gonna lose that night closing the
position really is just kind of giving
black targets on these pawns but Bishop
b2 was a nice move by way e because it's
saying that you can trade but you
haven't really solved your problem here
I'm opening up the position and maybe
there's gonna be dark square tension
coming to the Kings side but okay all
the rez is easing the tension baby with
that little inadvertent air drum desk
drumroll okay like what he's doing as
well I think that we aren't thinking to
bishops
better than two nights but perhaps not
totally realizing that this still
Detention Center is hard for white to
deal with do you ever take on e5 and I
take back with my Depot my Brooke on DEA
has a new lease on the position and that
this beautiful file to work with but I
think long term this position is amazing
for white I think you just even consider
Queen takes a two here just to take a
pawn for your troubles I like that move
is actually a very nice move because
take that pawn I dare you and then you
can take on ds2 on e4 you have a week
like square is where I can put my queen
on d5 and put my rook on c4 close down
your dark square Bishop and just well
looks like it's looking three already
feels artificial enough to say I like
all the red this position right just
affected he even has the option to
completely close it up Knights versus
Bishop rook e3 feels very suspect anyone
a5 his next move actually my his next
move maybe should do a Amelie Queen p5
was a double attack on beats two and a
half five so he can scoop that up five
hop in the very near future
oh that's a nice point and maybe that's
why he didn't play d5 in addition to the
a pawn falling is now okay so this is
this is a practical move by way you
don't want to allow black to get d5 and
close at the change so even if you lose
a pawn you cannot afford for this Bishop
to be shut out of the game and I like
that move d5 just from that perspective
look at the e5 and c5 squares Dani
that's gonna be a few days I didn't say
I like White's position I said I liked
to d5 for the bishop big enough with
bishops feelings here I'm with you and I
see outsider with lot of numbers
speaking a Morse code over there Robert
Dani kudos Ali Riza for not getting
frustrated I agree I agree that what he
said that was his own kryptonite right
that if he can get go until it's he can
get frustrated I'm thinking about Queen
63 here by the way but I think she's
taking on a 2 is better and the reason
why I want to take on c3 as I say good
luck tell the rest of your pieces I'll
play quickly put my rook on c3 but my
next work on c8 and and and you said you
take care of other people's pieces look
how eager you were to give up all the
rez was Queen shame on you mr. Hess well
I knew Queen Daisy was better but it
just felt if he just blooded that Queens
hey I could I never attack
man for for a suggestive Queen sacrifice
okay because when they work that's the
best part of chess all right but here
comes a four and we may get our Queen
sacrifice for two rooks or okay one a
takes B 3 B takes a two now now I really
like that idea in fact you think he's
gonna think about a four here yeah he
only has a minute
actually no Queen 84 I forgot that's a
safe square yeah you can get out right
Queen a for Queen C 4 you don't have to
sack the Queen but I think a four might
be what the doctor ordered oh absolutely
in it yeah there it is go for it I like
it
if you move Europe to be four there's a
three I think right my queen still
getting traps in now way to weed then he
was looking once not a three but you
still get a you still get basically the
same type of position you were talking
about he's going for it
oh you sank the queen of b2 and just
yeah I like it
it's the transition you mentioned
earlier on c3 wait oh never mind never
mind
okay that was like what if I just remove
my bishop and then wait d5 is also
hanging here so what's happy here the d5
pawn is also hanging on Rick a1 that's
the idea c4 okay Warren is trapping the
Queen oh my god did the Queen has no
squares rook c2 is also trapping the
Queen oh my did he just miss that oh my
gosh so Robert I was highlighted rook a
one wasn't as big with her as we thought
anyway because d5 was hanging but this
trick there's no way all here as a salt
as he's shaking his head like what that
came out of nowhere
WTF always means why the face and he's
look at it wayyyyy and he's like why the
face bro what's going I did why are you
doing this to me with the Queen traps oh
my gosh and that's a huge turnaround
because it look like firoozeh was
gaining the upper hand and now he's
certainly not in at work c2 traps that
Queen c2 III is just a bluff rook c2 and
it's over oh my gosh
it's ganking did he miss that well I
guess they say you green still trash so
I guess he's like I always take your e
pawn doc don't worry about it but but
rook c2 is cut what of what a tricky
little transition well the time
situation though wait him why is he
waiting
we missing I don't think we're missing
anything he's just saying how to trap
the Queen take on a one-play groped ac3
and somehow absolutely pray that you can
hold this position but you're in big
trouble but look at White's King it's
not that safe so that actually working
immediately they just play rook e8 and
then H forces Bishop f1 and now rookie
ones coming anyway and look for these
Knight and rooks to have a say here
we're gonna have a time scramble it's
not over when Queen takes 8383 with f3
okay yeah that is an opportunity okay
but you can still take a three now if
your wayi and rook e1 is met by Queen d4
where's blacks next move that's a great
question
I like Queen d4 do it it hits the night
even on Knight III you can take with the
rook okay he doesn't go for it 93 93
you're gonna give up the rook which is
why I wanted my Queen on d4 hitting b6
right I like it a lot better but I don't
think you saw that
what's the reason thinking about they're
both thinking all the rez is trying to
come up with something at the last
second he's gonna try to bring the other
rook in okay now White has rook e8 oh
that's it that's over yeah he shakes his
head that was not not ideal
Queen a3 look at that hits the rook hits
d6 yeah no just
h3 and there's no more 93 for f6 Wow oh
that is that is a comeback victory for
the Chinese kid welcome to the super GM
Club let's remind everybody of our daily
question okay which is important because
with that victory by Wei Yi he says you
may have just crossed 2,700 for those of
you who didn't know ali reza with a
victory in turkey has just crossed 2,700
but guess what that doesn't necessarily
make him a super GM yet or does it give
your vote on twitter use the hashtag
speech yes and let us know is 20 Robert
I have my ideas of what defines the
super Jim but I'm gonna let you guess
your number first we're gonna let the
fans get involved we'll get some tweets
and going but let us know what you think
really defines a super GM because wayy
is an undeniable super GM as he's up
three games in this match all the reza
he's in his back is against the wall
do you want me to answer that now let's
wait till we get more from the fans cuz
a pair I'm just being told we have an
impromptu Photoshop challenge going on
okay based on based on Robert has
telling us how much he enjoyed the new
Lion King with the exception of
Beyonce's voice as Nala a parent of more
time with us later but Wei Yi is
welcoming Simba to the twenty 700 club
and I don't even know who that came to
us from but thank you for that beautiful
piece of art Disney don't sue us that is
hilarious
fYI Disney is the one company you don't
mess with even for a second IP but
nobody watches chess shows let's be
honest back to the game look at you got
upset with me I didn't diss Beyonce what
I said was her voice was distracting
because I kept thinking of her in some
of her other roles and it was just like
hard to paste into the Lion King did you
express your feelings you express your
feelings there's nothing wrong with that
I'm saying there's a alright queen de8
again we've had a lot of Lopez both for
white and black Ferruccio now with about
15 minutes left in the five-minute time
control would really like to bring this
within it within two games maybe even
one before they head before they head
into the three-minute yeah
and right now fruisé you're trying to
get himself together gather his
emotional state and with Bishop to b3
he'd play that as a prophylactic move
stopping any Knight takes d4 word the
Queen and Bishop were lined up on the
bishop on a four so a 1954 shot was in
the cards for black and now blacks
position is awkward why is your queen
me8 rather than on a square like east 7
you might go queasy 7 now but then the
real question is was pushing the white
Bishop to b3 advantageous for black at
all or did that actually help white and
it's hard to say though right because
often the bishop is on b3 in these
structures anyway after black plays b5
so the fact that you voluntarily did it
and black hasn't advanced the b-pawn
that's also a little nuance right
because sometimes the be 500 of being a
target for white with ideas like a 4
right I'm not trying to defend way Yi's
decision there I'm just saying it's an
interesting little little weird trick
right the Queen e8 discovery battery
said we're now getting a structure we're
very familiar with but with pieces not
on their most normal squares yeah and
the a3 saying I don't want you to ever
play 90 85 and kick my bishop off the
diagonal I like that yeah it's a nice
way to just keep that Bishop alive when
it's best you live its best life and for
black I often think about Knight h5
ideas to go to f4 but white can also
play Knight c4 as a response angle feel
free to try to get to f4 I can always
catch you there and give you double
pawns all the resident in trying to get
that that good Iranian wrap going in his
head you know we can start bobbing his
head and having a better time because
right now he's got to change the mood
note that a3 will keep the bishop on
this diagonals Robert said because
there's never a Bishop e6 challenging it
without a d5 for key mode so so I'm like
an only reza's ition - honestly the more
the more this goes because f5 just feels
so double-edged right that's why you
maybe play King h8 if you were wayy to
unpin the pawn yeah that feels like a
ball he goes for it I was just gonna say
that feels like a move you're gonna wish
you could have back but he completed my
sandwich by playing the f1 hey I'm
getting hungry what kind of sandwiches
it as long as you keep completing my
sandwiches sandwiches then will doesn't
look at one together ticket subs maybe
fresh-baked bread though not like the
subway kind like real fresh sounds good
but you know what Daniel I'm curious
would you take on f5 here for white and
say I'm gonna open the e-file or do you
think that allows blacks go GF and check
on Eve for let's go to the Batcave let's
go to the Batcave and find out if takes
G takes you also loosen the night and it
makes Knight g5 start calling my name I
don't know if you take with a piece you
allow a fork emote right ride everything
with the pawn back so you take with the
poem but then 95 there's threats of
Knight f7 and Queen takes h5 and the e
pawn is pinned I don't know dynamically
like I said when f5 was played it feels
like a move way he's gonna wish you
could have back and I like white here if
firoozeh can can calculate this out well
I feel I'm I think we're gonna have to
agree to disagree it's up Queen g6 just
give me that open file and you like
black I love check many people
man you know feels beating he takes e5
first maybe that's the difference now
when he takes at five Robert if I takes
she takes Knight g5 say goodbye to your
queen g6 coz d7 hangs all right well I
see I see your point that actually might
be a more precise move water I agree
with that Robert you have changed yeah
no I'm still wearing the same Ninja
Turtle shirt don't worry he's I think
he's a bit concerned though about giving
black such a large center because if you
do take on a five in a lot of this
Pawnee for the night comes to e5 I can
understand why that would worry you and
you plays Knight III right away saying
well my pony's gonna hop right to d5
your name is Evan I your men eh5 wants
to share that f4 square with the pawn
there's a pretty awkward peace out there
yeah okay
and normally pieces can't live in the
center this long a pawn will try to kick
it out but e pawns don't move backwards
and the C pawn is gonna be hard to push
without without something like Knight b6
coming in anyway yeah I like this by
firoozeh
also would like that he's finding it
quickly because the biggest issue in a
five-minute portion of all things
firuze has been the slower player yeah
we just certainly been surprising but I
really like what he's done he regarded
that Bishop from B 3 where it's an empty
diagonal to e2 or maybe later to f1 to
protect the King side to allow for any
kind of B for a for b5 type pushes I
like before now I guess just to deny
these squares from the night although
Knight c5 is not like it's but I don't
really want to allowed Knight c5 with e4
so I would play b4 here yeah the only
downside of before was it black like
Bishop 8th right that would be really a
bit of a nuisance I'm just saying it's
amazing for black but perhaps that's the
one thing that all the reason was trying
to evoke a bit but now nice c5 can come
in and what are you gonna do just play
Bishop up fall under guard the pawn yeah
isn't a four point hanging though okay
yeah he does it we'll see if he likes
your before or if it's Queen c2
wait a second I know oh my gosh wait
laughing in the face of danger we knew
he was Simba
so he says I don't even care about the
e4 pawn bro
does that make way he scar are you
trying to make him the bad guy here I
didn't say that
but he's laughing in the face of danger
and I'm danger in every young cub needs
to wander out into the danger with the
hyenas every once in a while the great
bones gosh I wanna see you know 94
hitting hitting c3 maybe but I'm gonna
question this decision because I feel
like he was on the grind in a safe way
but maybe I'm wrong maybe the opening of
the e-file here and it is gonna
ultimately backfire for for black yeah
the only way I can see this being useful
or particularly useful for blacks if you
take an f2 and go for and Chuck tried
some sort of attack on the door would be
crazy right I don't think it works I'm
am going for my mantra they're not my
pieces so I'm gonna sack them but it
that sort of thing would be my main
concern for white because otherwise why
just goes Bishop anywhere and the e4
Knight is on the attack
'if I was vulnerable where's this route
gonna feet going
sorry diamond remember real Greco says
Dani is definitely Simba and Hess's Zazu
[Laughter]
you know what's funny is you and I were
singing I just can't wait to be king
before we went live this morning well
you know I think it's time that you and
I and little hearts are as I would say a
Simba Kings don't need advice from
little hornbills for a start all right
he started it Bishop d3 hits e5 Knight
g5 is coming that rook is running out of
squares 95 just do it the whole position
is falling it's just a collapsing Center
and and firoozeh
takes a sip of whatever that delightful
turkish drink is and he is ready it'd be
funny that I'm just like a Lipton iced
tea or something
American import
you know all right Rosie six now there's
Bishop b4 with my force any four yeah me
too
okay it's more I love it he takes e5 d7
take g7 do it quickly play Queen d2 use
the e-file and shake what your mama gave
you yes he does it is white up a pawn
what's up on yep f4 is falling you know
three key six okay I would keep the rook
on the board or is he gonna trade and
play Bishop e4 or Bishop c4 I think both
are probably good you take t1 yeah my
instincts that kept the rook on the
board but then I started calculating if
you take they can't they have to take
with the knight to guard f4 and then you
can play moves like Bishop b4 or Bishop
c4 maybe that's what he has in mind
whoa wait he's saying I don't I'm gonna
give you a four yeah because you want to
take b3 but ninety four solves that yeah
oh gosh okay Queen e2 is possible Bishop
b4 is also possible even age four just
trying to collapse the pawn chain h4 and
he likes it look at you your chess
whisperer
I mean somebody Robert Redford would
definitely play you in the Lifetime
movie that's coming out soon the
Lifetime movie about the reels özil
Robert Hess Robert Redford you just
you're just trying to get under my skin
I know it alright 57 the Queen's gonna
take you eight fish of efore Robert you
with me I'm here come here Simba okay
take on f5 plate or b7 okay yeah this
looks good Queen takes a six also
threatens Queen h6 at this point it
should be good enough given that the
time is probably gonna be where Yi's
demise we need range for is not quite
than me and just like that just like
that Wei Yi now only with a two-game
lead as we head into what will I'm going
to officially call it
likely the last game here unless we see
a very quick blunder the last time I did
that in the match with a nice Giri
Robert on I think it was 2 whatever
about 10 days ago I said for sure this
will be the last game and somebody lost
within like 2 minutes so I'll try not to
jinx the players but very likely this is
the last game of the 5 minute portion so
if you're just joining us that means
you're super jacked because we still
have a 2 full hour session of chess
ahead we've got 3 minute we've got
bullet and we've got a match which is
what we said where you would need to do
in order to have a chance to beat all
the arezzo Ferruccio known as a bullet a
bullet monster right way he's gonna need
a lead and right now he's doing it so
I'm expecting we're in for a thriller
today yeah I'm with you but we were
talking about firoozeh
tilting earlier what he really hasn't
been getting the time positions he wants
in the last few games I know he won that
game where he trapped for his queen but
funny kind of got lucky there
yeah he got very fortunate yeah vision
was out playing him throughout that game
so it feels like in the last batch of
games
firuze has had the upper hand he's still
down 2 games so it's frustrating for
both players as we get closer and closer
and closer to the bullet portion I think
he has to start sweating because he
knows that all there is is such an
amazing bullet player but as you pointed
out earlier dannion is a great call in
this match itself it seems like firuzan
has been down on the clock more often
which is surprising us considering how
quick of a player he is and once again
we've seen that change the faster the
time control sometimes it's like a reset
button right sometimes players are
slower in 5 minute and still faster and
bullets so but no I agree I mean I would
argue part of the reason for who's been
down on the clock is because look at the
scoreboard he's been getting outplayed I
guess if you look at most the games
right and that happens when you're when
you're in worse positions you use more
time so okay but here firoozeh
he's getting aggressive this is gonna be
a the kind of game that we could ask for
to bring the 5-minute second link to a
close yeah where I was gonna say Dan is
look at the Queen on e 1 it was clear
that I think King H 1 and Queen e1 white
one to play f2 to f4 and instead you're
now queen is on e1 awkwardly place and
black got an f5 I would take on e4 right
now yeah I love this move by firoozeh
just put me six develop and you have the
night after he is actually stuck there
because the f2 pond will be hanging in
there enough to River moves which just
keeps I don't quite stuck in this place
in an unfortunate way each six I don't
think that's necessary so yeah it seems
like it may be unnecessarily passive
move I mean white even maybe has the
time for something like h3 now if you
want if you'd be very careful because at
some point black may just take
everything on f2 normally you're not
looking to give up two minor pieces for
a rook but if it leads to a lot of
tactics on the F file black will do it
for sure that's why Bishop e6 I thought
was a good starting point because there
were ideas Bishop takes d5 and pawn to
e4 sort of situations to make White's
life difficult and c3
similarly feel slow I thought why was to
put h3 kicked that night away from g4
because I don't want to keep the night
there forever it's really annoying piece
and so right now I think you might have
been worried about something with Knight
takes up too and well let's let's go to
the Batcave and analyze because I looked
at a position where if h3 came take take
shake and bake and then Knight d4 and
combine that with threats like Bishop
takes h3 I think this is what he was
worried about so he was trying to just
pile up pressure on the Knight f3 yes
pp on the pp as they say put pressure on
the pin piece maybe g4 would be the only
response there but it looks right okay I
mean we agree right that's that that's a
very dangerous position for a white to
open up I feel like now's an even worse
version okay you ambition be six I was
just 97 because he just I was gonna say
now way he has time though now he's
guarded d4 so if he wants to play h3 and
we get the same types of variations
there is no Knight d4 with the follow-up
pressure so but there's Pawnee for after
I take on d5 so I think that's why that
is hanging but but yeah I hear you so I
thought about the 97 rather than Bishop
e6 was the move because then you're oh
very nice yeah so 97 would have had the
same idea let's show Roberts point
because we're calculating like madman
here they don't pay us enough to
calculate like this Robert but we're
doing it anyway
you know I thought h6 tip with a g5
square so you might as well have made
use of it okay well he does Altima just
retreat the night we're still all
centered around this tension of whether
h3 will come or if it comes too late
Queen e8 by firoozeh heading to h5 shy
don't you dad the background don't let
your kids drink too much red bull dad
look at the peace development here what
is whites Queen side doing the answers
nothing and black cuz all the pieces are
very active here in Queen h5 kind of
plays itself so I would recommend that
as a move g5 is probably always thinking
about right now I'm saying should I do
it but the problem is if you had g5
might have five is of course gonna be
played immediately saying go ahead and
win a pawn I love your light square
isn't gonna be an issue that's a
thrilling way to give up a pawn right
you would love to open up this bishop
and have a whole lot of light squares to
go with it right you know sign me up for
that compensation ya know that looks
phenomenal for what look at it the way
you feel like way ease dealt with the F
file pressure well I mean look at what
where's this position going Knight a5
might be happening on the board
regardless yep yeah I think this this
position has turned around so if
firoozeh had something he might have let
it slip and by the way Robert this is
the last five minute game time is
officially up we will be headed to three
minute right after this so so yeah yeah
and this is a big moment for ali riza
because he's down two games if he can
win this one and go into the three
minute segment just down one game he's
feeling very confident should if I were
him very good about being out three nil
start off losing the first three games
and then if you can say okay I've won
plus two since that initial horrible
stretch you have to be feeling good
about yourself right now is way he's
time I really feel like he's gotten the
better of the last series of yips I was
gonna say the opposite story line is you
you had a good game here at a chance to
be down only one if you lose this one is
parousia you're down three games
totally different right I mean the tilt
could be real there and I yeah I'm
getting nervous about how where this is
headed for Purusha yeah I liked his
position way more earlier in the
is waiting to play f4 and that's such a
double-edged move and the reason I say
that is you're getting advancing your
position you can go f5 at some point if
you really feel like you but you also
leave your Center much more loose by
playing with like f4 so he's taking his
time cuz it's okay he goes for it's
gonna say it's super double-edged and
note that if white gets f5 now watch out
for things like h3 and this Bishop has
to be careful about running out of
squares but I'm worried about f4 if
black just takes it and tries to play
like d5 or even Knight d5 there's all
kinds of pins here right and then the
White Queen was gonna go to g3 and then
attack the g7 square so ah very nice
okay yeah he sat with rook e8 but now I
guess f5 Queen f6 the bishop does not
get trapped because that's this way as
ready to have seven and the name h4
needs defense as well it's an
interesting decision to play a5 rather
than just like call the bluff and build
the tension rook a you want or something
I think if I'm gonna play Bishop f3 and
it's like rook G 1 G for chief I'm just
trying to crash through but obviously
black is not gonna sit in a lot of
everything the positional break black
wants here at some point is d5 this
would undermine efore and then we can
have five everybody so way he has to to
be aware that black is not just gonna
sit tight as Robert says he's gonna get
d5 as soon as he can yep so I like this
picture f3 move a lot he's just really
trying to go rook g1 and push the Jeep
on page 3 I think he'll play actually a
Brooke do you want black plays d5 anyway
cuz f5 is gonna fall is there some kind
of no rook F to probably doesn't work I
want to go rook up to Bishop h5 pawn to
g4 and claim that I'm trapping your
bishop
over there on the h3 square but my
knight on each 4 is always hanging I
think doesn't work oops he didn't play
oh he did play Bishop e2 I thought I
just clicked Bishop e2 but he played it
alright okay Bishop g2 and we might get
a game of tickle here if black plays
Bishop g4 it's uh
Nietzsche no he doesn't want to draw or
she wants the whole thing whoa and the
time situation it is essentially a
bullet game from here on out and it
takes to the king I assumed he was
insane with the King yep he does and d5
your mum waiting for d5 you know I
wanted
I've been calling for it he's gonna
prepare it for some reason well see for
let's see for maybe there's some kind of
see 596 94 things
ah that's a good point let's show that
on the analysis board real quick Robert
Hess bringing it like it's hot if C 4 C
5 and we transition to an outpost square
always be aware of your pawn structure
kids D 5 gets in now F 5 is undermined
okay so actually I'm sort of like black
solution more and more kingdoms yeah I'm
wanting D 5 that's why I wanted C 4 but
as you pointed out C 5 would be a
problem so I feel like and the reason we
love D 5 Robert not just cuz it
undermines f 5 but look at the king
right the more open this gets right the
white emperor has no clothes here you're
gonna start feeling the draft on the
diagonals and the second-ranked yeah 96
is a way to trying to get rid of your
bad piece in age for for a 97 that's
sitting pretty but 19 to g6 pawn takes
Queen takes g6 here and as you mentioned
the second rank this is the key C - yep
all right it's a trading off some oak so
rook takes d5 over it sees Fe check
first and that way after that's key and
check enough to back maybe one of those
games will for all our hard work we get
a peaceful result right hey come on guys
we want blood although look at that look
at the bar you mentioned the connection
from China the server's about as far as
it gets from our Pacific based company
although we have servers all over the
world but I you look at that you look at
that and you wonder it's this time
Scrabble gonna come down to a bad
connection
you know these players know that that's
that's part of the deal you got to make
sure you're in a stable spot uh-oh oh no
is he thinking it looks like he was
actually thinking there but he is gonna
get down on the clock here it's also
hard because he barely moves he's such a
stoic player like I said he's got
resting chess face we're gonna do here
rook f2 or Queen e2 he's gonna try to
just pee this one up but firoozeh wants
to take advantage of this time scribble
don't get him wrong a this is his chance
yep problems we have for was a move
there the G Paul was pinned in
would have fallen oh you're actually
miss dip Brooke f4 was a chance that all
the rest just missed can you just play
h5h for like can you just try to poke
and prod of the King sign okay still
think all you res is gonna get this game
just knowing you know he's infiltrating
yeah okay but the queen is gonna come to
e2 and you're gonna have to either back
up or trade that's true yeah I think
only Reza missed his chance to win this
game with that Brooke up form of the
endings still better than a more active
rubber t1 time okay hanging Oh be pawns
gonna fall a 4 it gets traded time oh my
oh he played a move with less than a
second what I'm nervous he's barely
getting these moves he takes before
rooks see to it okay pre move to gain a
little bit of tip back but it wasn't
enough rooks e4 check in d4 check on d4
you win the b4 pawn or well you're gonna
take on e4
yeah I think he should have taken on e4
that was that would have been the better
try for a win
what is it my gosh this is who said rook
endings were an exciting Robert or okay
don't play before I'm very confused now
I don't know anything I don't know who's
who's trying to flag who here but way he
has worked his way back into this game
winning play b2 b2 kimchi to just bring
your king jinji brand King around to the
C pawn yeah at the e point I don't know
if it's winning because the e bugs gonna
make him have to make a decision before
the King can just walk like he's not
winning I don't think it's winning this
isn't like a Giri Anand yesterday work
were Geary lost to a similar idea at the
Grantchester
this is a different scenario cuz the e
pawn prevents the black King from just
rookie mistake he 7 like what is okay we
don't it's not important but I thought
he could have done something a little
earlier now yeah I think it's just a
draw
can we progress here he goes for it
he wants to flag him oh my god there was
a queen on the board now is he gonna
play da Queen the e7 you guys we know
eating any a okay you could even trait
is that King opponent no the Kimo name
is losing weight
well you had a a queen there did I gosh
you're right he had he a queen on rookie
six wait you could have one heap removed
rookie six in you yeah oh he was
laughing about it as he should be he got
away with one that sly little dog
silly silly cage tricks are for way ease
is he frozen oh my god no he's really
frozen oh my gosh firoozeh is pumped oh
my gosh firoozeh just stole one
literally stealing victory from the jaws
of a draw
where shakes his head I hunt you old for
this Robert I got confused me so much no
Queen okay yeah the the key was right
here everyone in case you're wondering
ali reza had pre moved rook takes c6
because he anticipated rook takes b2 way
he tricked him with a 700 just take here
but ali reza had pre move rookie six and
white was winning on the spot with the
movie a queen rook takes b6 and queen d8
fork town win town way he would have
been up three games town as we head to
three-minute town that's craziness now
we're gonna go to break town and
everyone you're not going anywhere all
14,000 of you are gonna be in for a
treat
ali reza just by the hair on his chinny
chin chin and you know he's only got a
couple he brings this thing to a
one-game lead as we go to a break robert
sit tight we'll be right back
[Music]
a Premium Membership at chess comm we'll
help you improve your game with full
access to a powerful set of learning
tools unlimited tactics let you practice
like a master with more than 50000
puzzles to challenge you at every level
our library of interactive chess lessons
created by master coaches will enhance
every aspect of your game and after each
game you play the computer analysis
feature will give you feedback on every
move you play turning every game into a
chance to learn and that's not all
premium benefits also include unlimited
tournaments video lessons the opening
Explorer and much much more upgrade now
to take your game to the next level
and the jr. speech Chess Championship
continues and exciting news for all
15,000 viewers that are here right now
as this thing is lit is we're gonna play
a game a game that we've never played
before in a game that Robert has didn't
know we were gonna play it's a very
simple one
Robert we'd like you to watch the stream
and name that player as you see them on
the screen we get prepared we're gonna
see if we can trick you into anything
but make sure you follow closely and
name that player right when you see the
card ready set go
who do you see on the screen I know
you're on a little too late go ahead
Magnus Fabiana and Yishan and Caro
you pass round one let's go again Oh
Bogdanovich and Marie sebab okay
barely got that one right this next one
should be a little bit easier it's tough
for Usha wayyy
making me the next one the next one is
the hardest of all so wait oh well you
you just got the news and we've got the
news that you are the wild cut you are
given a wild-card spot to the feed a
grand Swiss and you will be competing at
the Isle of Man Wow how pumped are you
about this I mean that's exceptional I'm
honored I'm ready to play you know I'm
happy to fight with the best of them we
know you are in Robert jokes aside I
know we I know we sprung that game on
you to make this big announcement to all
of our fans but you've got so many
supporters here at chess calm and so
many people were already looking forward
to the feed a grand Swiss because of
those names you named Magnus Carlsen
Fabiano Caruana Hakkar nakamura etc but
now they have you to follow and tell
everybody how pumped you are in this
opportunity how much are you looking
forward to the feed a grand Swiss I'm
stoked I mean it's gonna be one of the
best events of all time I'm taking it
very seriously I know you know everybody
here sees me commentating they don't get
to see me play as much but it's really
an honor for me to return to the board
and play against the very best in the
world I'm going to take it with pride
I'm taking in stride and I'm ready to
take on anyone who's in front of me well
and seriously everyone is thrilled about
this you've been playing some of the
best chess of your life lately and not
not just because you win tournaments
like arena kings but you're you're your
inspiration to get back and to really
jump that jump even more levels over the
board what what is what is fueling that
fire for you what makes you want to want
to play and compete again with the best
in the in the world we know you're
capable of doing it so what what is what
is the fire there for you about
I mean honestly just playing the best
players and I think the problem in chess
is you know I think even for the top
players they get tired of playing each
other all the time
and just like a tennis right you can see
Roger Federer lose a match to somebody
who is professional but maybe not in the
top 10 in the world chess is the same
way in any one game something like that
can happen and I think I'm most
motivated by even having the possibility
of playing the top players but that
climb is an arduous task is very
financially difficult and so you know
I'm honored to be invited to that event
and I'm just looking forward to last
year played Michigan on I was able to
draw the legend one of my chess heroes
and I hope I get more opportunities like
that well that's awesome and we're
excited for you congratulations of
course we will have coverage of the Isle
of Man as everyone knows starting in
October when that major major event as
Robert said may be one of the greatest
grain may be the one of the greatest
Swiss is we you will ever have in the
history of the game right with those
types of players so all right as we get
ready here for the three minute portion
Robert back to the focus on these but I
love to talk about you all day you know
that I won't talk about you and your
chess you know chess without house but
we got to talk about these guys and the
three minute is underway so here we go
how do you feel like that hang over
there is gonna affect ye losing that
game I'm just distracted now I know how
I'm gonna commentate after all that good
news you know especially because behind
the scenes I was being trolled by the
one and only Nick Barton so yeah for
trying to convince me that it was all a
lie
but I'm stoked and right now if you're
with wayyy and this g6 line I'm not sure
he should keep going through it because
as a as a converted Stein it's deferred
player myself like I used to play these
d6 Bishop d7 structures I know that for
white you get a big Center and just firm
control over the poor and so right here
look at the position look at this crud I
understand that way you feels
comfortable with this type of setup but
if I played Bishop c2 and I asked black
what is your next two moves and
everybody's Bishop C - what take Oh give
me the center give me the whole thing do
you think this is prep though given the
way way he's playing cuz this was the
line we just had where where you play
Queen e8 and he's decided to go back to
it so I hear you and I'm wondering why
do you think he's going back for this if
you just feel this is just a positive
transition to the middle game I just
don't understand it if I'm being honest
I think it just looks okay as for white
and look at this Queen on e is misplaced
piece you have white has the e in deep
pawns in control over the central
squares black's pieces are restricted
you could take the bishop there and I
take C - Queen C - the downside your c7
pawns now when they're attack and I mean
it just feels really really nice and
easy to play for white and look how
quickly through just played this game
he's already out 12 seconds and I think
that will continue to rise rook a to c1
mems continue putting pressure on the C
pawn it looks good to me
well again if you're happen to be just
joining us this has been a match where
Wei Yi for the most part dominated the
five-minute segment he was up three
games at one point but as firoozeh found
himself and clearly looking at the
scoreboard he clawed his way back into
only be trailing a game and the big
storyline is as the time control goes
faster we'll weigh Yi continue to be
able to keep up with with the speed
demon ferocious oh yeah right now the
fact that you highlighted the clock
thing is a big thing I'm gonna keep
focusing on and now are there are there
east six tactics coming I'm spying a g6
pawn you know I don't know any better no
he's definitely something to keep an eye
on here but I think you can take on e5
pretty bishop back to g7 so okay he does
it right away he's allowing the
discovery what is that a Oh Gary why
didn't he take d6 though wasn't that a
free pawn oh yeah actually that's
something maybe just see takes d6 bad oh
okay that's interesting right let's
analyze that everybody if I missed it
some of you might have missed it I know
that's probably a stretch but if takes
d6 166 and we just have a big trade okay
my bad I was I was very confused by that
white plays 94 not only renewing
pressure on d6 but likely actually the
threat of at night f6 check is is pretty
scary yeah okay so Bishop f5 I think
Queen b3 get out of the pin the second
one on b7 looks good
Bighorn Queen c3 were new your pressure
and support of these dark square pawn
chain okay I like that I sort of like
playing on the white squares because I
think that blacks gonna take on e4
regardless so I might as well
five yeah you could play d5 here I'll
stay eeep on his pins I could start
looking like Queenie six not good play
you it make it means you almost have c5
okay he didn't do it but I was wondering
with that Danny your move was good yeah
once you pointed out the pawn was pinned
I was thinking c5 might have been really
strong for black Wow yeah and here I
think that poems blockaded quite nicely
but we've seen for usually get the night
versus the bishop in that French game
earlier and so it seems that's a dynamic
that is gonna play a part in this match
right now I think that black is very
close to just taking advantage in this
position okay
a4 is a huge necessity because b5 c4 you
don't want to see those pawns go forward
on the Queen side now you show that your
pawn minority two pawns for white versus
three pawns for black your two pawns
control all three black pawns that's
good news for you but the e5 pawn at any
moment can turn from the strengths into
a liability
Queen e6 oh wow I was gonna say if you
allow east six now the King if black
plays Queen e6 and he does it I like
this you're giving up b7 happily if you
get things like rook b8 I thought no
he's got rookie somebody trapped the
Queen again
firuze you literally just did one of
those like you've gotta be right oh my
gosh the second time he's trapped his
old queen second time oh my god if
you're just joining us in epic fashion
in the five-minute segment way he was
getting outplayed and swindled his way
to a victory by trapping all here as his
queen deja vu all over again
thank you Yogi Berra Wow oh my gosh he
must be so you know so funny if you're
talking about storylines we expected we
expect all arrested to be faster and
Ollie resid to be the one with trickier
swindles today where has been faster and
he has swindled himself out of it
these two if not three bad games right
yep it's been fascinating that was
unreal just the Queen was trapped we
need to be seven lovey you're gonna lose
the beat you know what a
counterintuitive blow to right like if
you if you look at this game everybody
the next ones getting started but I'm
gonna analyze the position we just saw
here just to show you real quick that
again like even the strongest players
can miss things like that because very
rarely will you see a queen trapped with
so many open squares at least optically
open right if you look at them visually
it feels very very obvious the Queen
should have some way out you grab that
pawn and don't think twice and then
rookie seven I mean you saw I suggested
B seven was a good idea to get to hang
because of maybe rook b8 but rookie
seven and the Queen set of squares
Robert even the best players can miss
tactics like that as we go back to the
main game right because they're just not
patterns that you see every day if we're
talking pattern recognition and how the
best players become them right
yeah they see patterns and that was just
awkward let me totally honest I also
forgot about rookie seven because you're
so focused on winning back the pawn that
you stole you sometimes forget wait a
second my Queens actually just trapped
there and firoozeh
now with the black pieces has the two as
a two bishops I saw Dee
I saw the doubled pawns and assumed the
assumed that the bishop pair was given
up to get him but nope they're white
still has two official so what is down
in development and in black and somehow
accurately push for here I would try to
get to the c-4 square with my knight
there he goes ninety eight ninety six
ninety four also lying to Bishop we go
to f6 which is challenging black screen
side I like the opening choice by fusion
this game especially after a loss yeah
especially after a loss but if you take
back that last game we had in the five
minute segment for those you might have
missed it we're way II really shouldn't
have lost eventually lost on in a time
scramble like if you're if you're
firoozeh you got to be feeling a little
nervous but how the blitz is going you
could be down three games right now and
you're down by two although the other
way to look at that as well I could be
down more and you know I'm just happy to
be within a couple games as bullet nears
yeah no I honestly don't know who should
be happy right now because right okay
wait you should be happy is up to games
but
considered the trajectory starting up
3-nil and these weird games I think fer
who just probably really ticked off
about blundering his queen a second time
but I also think that he can be pretty
confident with how his chest is being
played yeah okay well now before
is played feels like black should have
the better of this end game even if he
decides to just take on c3 and isolate
and double those two those two pesky but
okay but don't forget bish before is
threatening e5 which is a four key mode
so let's let's not blunder in one move
so I was gonna say it's black want to
play g5 and he buys it and now the
question is just white one of the e5 is
a response just saying let's trade
bishops in an unconventional way and
both of us will have weird problematic F
pawns
yeah this but this is a tough question
to a wayy right because you'd like to
keep the bishop on this you know now g3
kind of d6 c7 diagonal but then you're
fully abandoning ideas if firoozeh can
somehow find a way into like the d4
square so it's very dangerous to put the
bishop there but if you backup then you
kind of just wasted a full tempo right
Bishop e3 might be met by Knight c4 as
you said yep so what to do right way E
is clearly not sure because he's already
used almost 40 seconds on this one move
and the time has turned around okay he
commits the g3 but look for firoozeh to
try to make tactics work here on this
King on f2 he keeps the bishop on this
diagonal for that reason he'll probably
just play h6 yep he does and I like c5
coming for black to use the d4 square
yeah there's also idea c5 or b5 and just
challenging that knight on c3 there you
go full b5 before that's how you would
do you know sometimes you just got to do
it yeah and now that she's a real tough
situation for white because a one-hand I
want to play e5 94 but I understand that
Knight f5 is coming and my bish bunch
III isn't so happy does that a
prophylactic move prophylaxis killed the
cat I like be fine though I like it
though ferocious feeling it right 94
look at that ferocious got that boyband
swoon face going he's gonna go 94 and
take back with the b-pawn why
do your do your boyband spoon face for
me my wait band spoon face
yeah he's got like like he's singing and
serenading you like like how we did with
the Backstreet Boys that's why they had
him in the band no other reason just to
take your shirt off and get wet and give
us your smug face I went for it you you
miss Howie it's already happened no I
saw it I loved it thank you for the
swoon all right Aoife all right he's
gone you could okay you don't you would
go to be seven if you could get the c-5
square but you don't want white to get
before so oh okay what's D for yeah but
Bishop d3 here just covering c2 reigning
1965 and I can come to c5 isn't there a
lot of least squares yeah I'm not liking
the 94 plan as much either I'm with you
now I liked it at first but okay he
could still he could still try for c5
and c4 on Bishop b3 because the knight
does guard the b-pawn but I guess Bishop
d3 c5 white just maybe plays c3
undermine it oh you played sees me right
away
okay but maybe he likes the dark square
control he's willing to part with the
bishop pair because of this Knights kind
of new lease on life holding all these
squares look at this I mean I'm not
saying that black is better but at least
blacks not in danger of dick going down
a pawn or anything of that sort
so rook e8 here or trade first and then
go rookie something feels like this has
turned around at the time still favors
firoozeh especially because of scramble
we know of his bullet skills and wiki's
connection is is clearly not as stable
but but I like how way he got out of
that worst middle game I don't think he
should lose this one on the board
anymore at all yeah this one for what
vision when he five opposite bishops and
anything that black king isn't I was
gonna say black better be careful before
you open up the G file you might you
might regret that yep yep and I know
that it seems like Fuji was drinking a
lot of Red Bull here he's getting that
energy but you don't be over the
energetic in any game like this when
your king is the one who could be in
harm's way c7 is hanging at least seven
and a five right so do you
trade c7a five for f6 I guess you lose
the f3 pawn the end of that though
because I'll take very nice in your pawn
this is normally we have issues with
like the Fabiano fro where they lean in
and we get full forehead and hairline
this is like almost like put a new
mustache on faroush ax Photoshop contest
inadvertent give me a mustache that
firuze you should be proud of and you
get yourself a diamond membership
hashtag speech s on Twitter you're
welcome by the way I don't need to show
what Robert analyzed as much as we got
distracted there because it actually
happened you got this Bishop to e fourth
fret which is what Robert said would be
the issue if if wait you went after the
a5 pond but still this should be a draw
barring some sort of blunder and time
pressure or some kind of disconnection
we've already seen disconnects lose way
again time pressure he's getting too old
for this Robert this has been like years
I have got to calm down a little bit I
have got to calm down in length
my name is f4 you have three he legit
has chances with way ye under time
pressure and the bishop C force mate oh
my god rookie to Bishop King p3 Bishop
c4 was made but he was running out to e5
anyway but you're right that was a nice
meeting in Sam oh my gosh now who's on
the mating grind look at this rook she
always got AJ rook e1 Jack Bishop e5
oh my TW for the win
the threat of rook AJ made forced
firoozeh to give up the exchange this is
nothing he's teasing me bananas and now
he's losing the bishop waiting oh my
gosh dude lady just one that came
already slap slam his desk
Perugia slammed his desk that was one of
the most ridiculous that was one of the
best - but that game sent a message do
not kid yourself if you're at home
firoozeh may be smiling but he slammed
his desk for a reason
because that was unbelievable that is a
game that shows that this bullet portion
is not going to be a walk in the park
everybody let me show you this
combination wayy at the last minute
walks the king of the board and plays
rook h5 threatening checkmate on h8
there's no way to stop it besides a
check on he won but Bishop e5 and you've
run out of moves there there's and this
would just lose the rook you have to
part with the rook in order to stop the
checkmate threat and in time pressure
way you not only found that combination
but then went on to win it creating new
mating threats against the black king
and for Russia blunders with Bishop e4
o-m-g xur snaps for realsies homie Wow
and look what fujas done in this game he
is just saying I'm gonna play squid he
has the same amount time to start with
he is playing insanely fast the position
is already unclear asymmetrical pawn
structure black us is a 6 to c4 chain
White is the huge center that Center it
can be a huge risk at the remove like
this would be 7 hitting before things of
that nature he goes g5 I like it
now play nice c3 okay you took back I
thought he's gone Knight c3 try to play
pawn to e5 and just flaps the center
instead he goes for this and I mean I
like blacks position here I don't
believe that this is actually a
dangerous for black I can always plant
my 26 to blockade the pawn I'm
putting my bishop on e7 or on chief 4e
even I I think that firoozeh
is trying to force a win where one
doesn't necessarily exist take on it for
just take it yeah just taking up for and
call the Queen SEC Purusha is being
being really really challenged here this
is just nuts people joining just now
10,000 of you thank you for being here
we have quite the match that scoreboard
favors that one seed overall you
shouldn't be surprised as far as that
goes but for many people this would be a
very big upset of way you can continue
to hold on especially given that he's
he's showing he can hang with firoozeh
and the most dangerous time scrambles so
yeah that's actually I Daffy to that
game I'm have to give the advantage to
Wei Yi or three games I understand the
bullet
but that was unbelievable it was amazing
yes Persia has to win this game because
right now he he's really in danger going
on Full Tilt a4 is a good move
undermining the c4 pawn but he needs to
get this one
I really believe well he certainly can't
lose if he loses and goes down for
psychologically and historically you're
up against the proverbial hey we've
almost never seen a comeback before
right so even in bullet three four games
is a lot to overcome but one of the
reasons I'm not really seeing a victory
or white in this game is look at the
kingside pawn structure so even if I
lose my three black pawns those two
white pawns in the queenside I don't
really see how white is gonna make
progress and when the King side with yep
f2 f3 double isolated I want to really
highlight Roberts point if everything on
the Queen side is lost and white has the
Queen versus even just the knight and
Bishop for black with the pawn structure
on the Kings side probably even their
black is holding given that these weak
pawns make it so hard for white to
create weaknesses against the Kings side
so that shows you how unlikely it is
that firoozeh wins this game so now it's
a little different because if white is
able to take away the Queen side pawned
by key and keep his own consent pawns
all you got to do is keep one right if
you can keep one pawn the Queen will
really flex her muscles against the rook
and Bishop helping another pawn here we
go that was I think that was a mistake
nobody's gonna take b4 not h6 if he
takes a 63
why do you rip c7 no-repeat' seemed much
more sensible to me oh yeah yeah I think
way you missed rook b8 winning b2 now
you might have to settle on f6 which is
never what you want to do when a queen
is playing against your conglomerate of
pieces because you've opened up your
King now for checking business so this
is this is favoring Ferruccio as far as
the direction yeah
alright he's not he's not even giving
him his bead points I don't want to give
you a pass pawn over there on the Queen
side so I'm gonna take that one to flex
the bishop away from that diagonal with
that sacrifice that F pawn wasn't needed
anyway and here he goes a5 Bruges is
gonna win he is gonna win just as we
were saying this is
kind of came to forgive really but you
know we talk about that a lot in these
formats Robert just that regardless of
our objective evaluation how much harder
it is even for the world's best to play
against the Queen
right in blitz because the way you the
way you win against the Queen is you
know really precise coordination your
pieces have to work together and
objectively speaking the best player
should do that but with little time on
the clock
how often have you when I see you and I
seen a queen win a game that she wasn't
supposed to win right absolutely happens
in this format a lot that nights
right nights are so tricky in blitz
chess because they fork you when you're
least expecting it and it's just it's
happened so many players but right now
version cuts the deficit of two games
he's going back to this weird variation
that I don't even know the name of this
is the günzburg variation of the four
nights it was early a3 by way II and III
don't believe in this line you can't
play Asian reso early which is doesn't
do too much it was black
opening in the center already castles
fully developed I think it has to be
even though I see these double bonds
which are not doubled anymore I think
black is doing perfectly fine here
yeah wait you called it at the end of
the five-minute fortune he's still up in
the match but regardless of some really
funny Queen sax and a few time scrambles
it feels like at some point the game
shifted firoozeh has not been worse at a
lot of these openings right right he's
been doing better from that regard so
let's see Ruby 8 what are you doing with
the Queen c2 I get wearing it baby baby
Bishop d3 yeah that's a fair point
Bishop e3 looks good Queen c2 similarly
we need for just Bishop f4 to assuming
mission f5 can't even say my squares
correctly attempts me d4 put my um the
eight ball is hanging and I don't think
there's an awkward queen trout there
yeah I wasn't going for a queen trap I
was giving you my a 7 pawn to probably
try to go like rookie Aidan is developed
shout-out to Diamond remember real Greco
no neither of these players played in
the protest League last year but Iran is
putting together a team that plans to
try to qualify for the 2020 protesting
C's
with firoozeh and MUC Sulu so watch out
for that and wayy has been tried to be
recruited by the xiang do pandas we also
have heard that there are two other
Chinese teams that plan to try to
qualify in october/november for the
protest League twenty20 season so thanks
for that question there but no neither
these players actually played in the PCL
last year there's powerhouses for sure
Queenie ate Queen c2 okay okay I mean
you've liked ferocious opening on a
structural level though right I mean
black still has some things to figure
out if you give white to three moves you
see rook d1 Bishop e3 and all of a
sudden these pawns are getting poked at
so so ferocious got the initiative to
prove here and look at that he goes
Queens e6 go d4 yeah your honesty
Sonny's pin that's how you do it that's
how you prove that initiative your
Bishop d3 move makes a lot of sense now
you know I love it it's rude eventually
gonna try to play Bishop e7 and play d4
intro to meet white somehow she's
ridiculous but usually I'm the guy with
made on the brain with you you have been
bringing those attacking ideas all day
you know it's it's the weekend also I'm
getting word that firoozeh played from
Montclair last year in the protest oh
yeah okay I'm sorry
I'm sorry I was I was thinking about the
fact that Iran didn't have a team when I
answered that because I know him in mock
Zulu are putting one together so my
fault and Matsu thought she played for
Armenia or something yeah he was on the
team yeah so Iran has never had a PCL
team but they are working on qualifying
so my bad but alright Bishop e3 a5
played very quickly note that d4 was no
longer an option because the bishop
defended the Queen
no more PP on the pp here today hey it's
a chess kid sponsored event you gotta be
mentioning fun Master Mike truisms put
pressure on the pin piece yep and a four
here well as any would be three the
bishop would have to be eight but you
know what I like I got no I got made on
the brain I like Queen e2 Bishop c2 and
relocate this battery for something
nasty on h7 you're all-in
I'm all-in
I also like Queenie to to go to h5 I'd
like this move Queenie to make it happen
I don't like Bishop d7 because it's a
Bishop g4 would have encouraged you to
play f3
Oh Bishop c4 would have been such an
irritating little move to deal with yeah
and that h3 says that's not happening
anymore but look at this look at the
eights coming very quickly and here
knows that's my Queen e2 I wanted it
wait h5 is gonna be the follow-up what
is black through here with Bishop c2
let's well Bishop C to beat oh you can't
take B to because in the end white head
Bishop h7 winning the work but he's not
afraid of Queen d3 who's Queen g6 and
say you're be two blondes week okay but
way is gonna start getting surgical here
we've got these weak pawns
I like Queen's things a lot g6 now g6 I
can trade up six and gobbledy five prove
me wrong you can O be to hanging though
maybe you're right you have a d7 thingy
leave my d7 Bishop alone hey hey hey hey
hey
there's no Bishop e6 or something c6 not
even better
thinking Queens okay yeah you're right
b2 is gonna fall in the end but maybe
they four pawns also weak yeah 20:49
gen'l'men who's better in that endgame
because black I had the rook on the
second right okay I guess why can't
really lose with the extra pawn right
actually that's an annoying game so yeah
if you take on before of rook takes d4
rook takes b2 we trade on between 84
falls and what's available pawn to rook
endgame yeah firuze just taking his time
to try to deal with that fighting for a
draw down with King g7 cuz then we're
gonna have a like what I like King g7 a
lot he says he hit the same position he
could have had with his King on g8 that
was a really smart transition you know
yeah yeah very nice he just bring his
king over in the seat bomb much better
drawing chances now with the King
activated rather than on g8
nice move c4 and all right oli deal
it'll stop by check but black will keep
the rook behind the C pawn and challenge
white saying the only way you can help
your C pawn really pushes by bringing
your King over to the Queen side way to
bring our King to the Queen side you're
gonna start losing some of your King
side pawns
shout out to Bigfoot Ted you know what I
maybe next time we grow our beards
together Robert sorry all right rook
anything I got distracted darn it darn
you BIC all right C 5 H 5 now play H 4
yep
H 4 we do these things quickly downtown
where ye pledged for now he's taking his
time we turn he's trying to be as you
said surgical by this ending was he very
precise yep and maximize his winning
chances he repeated once here so what is
the ideal way at some point why it's
gonna have to commit the king the King
journey right and what are you trying to
do is wipe before you commit to rushing
that came to help the C pawn well you
worry about your pawns collapsing right
as your King starts moving to the Queen
side have to because that's why I'm
asking so what is if we're trying to
give that education to the viewers what
is why trying to do before you
inevitably say I'm gonna rush and give
up the F pond and try to get a queen or
okay I'm just saying that as well looks
like he's almost submitting to a draw
okay maybe not but okay now's now you've
gone all the way in but that doesn't
necessarily help your winning chances
does it I guess it no there's the
winning games are very slim here and the
reason why is if you were to give me
your F pawn my king would then run up
the board now well now that the pawns on
c7 it's even less cos just to use your
imagination everybody even if this King
makes the long journey right if he goes
full Frodo right you're not even
threatening anything because now you
don't have any squares to hide behind so
faroush is gonna keep the rook down and
when this King comes up black will just
start checking and there's no there's no
umbrella to shield from the rain of
checks right and this is one of the
reasons why often in these endings you
try to keep the pawn one Square back so
that your King has the potential to hide
from checks but here way you was unable
to do that and ultimately I think this
is just going to end in a draw good
defense from faroush
though yeah no this is this is wait a
sec he's be careful now yeah you might
lose on time right okay but he there's
no way why should lose this one but when
you look at the connection and you and
you look at the time ticking you start
to get a little tingly inside the bad
kind
yeah also worrying about the h5 pond
sometimes as a pond that's wrong too far
but the good news for fridges even if
you lose that pond there are so many
drawing chances because the H I push
names hider can reach seven but here he
goes here's we trying his best
he's trying keep it still black black
just should just check and go back
there's no real frets here for white Oh
King g5 Oh King g5 and now okay but
white is in six long I'm very nice and
timely that's key the brook comes to c5
and I think we'll finally see a draw no
we won't
f6 coming where you want Seabrooke e7 I
realize that rook c5 check regards at
first rook f5 then take the pawn
they're trying to flag each other oh my
gosh I just surprised to see way you do
this because it just you feel like this
is firoozeh
territory that he's playing with fire on
the clock the way he's showing he's not
going to be a pushover in those
bullet-time scrambles huh check g5 check
if you're working faith still me wow
that's a beautiful stalemate oh my god
oh my gosh you've broken favourite g5
now we're in soon that would've been
sick I'll show that on the board
okay next games I'm gonna show you
exactly what Roberts just said as I go
full incoherent the key was way he
thinks he's found last-ditch winning
chances here with the combination rook
e8 followed by rook to f8 would look
winning right I'm gonna win the f7 pawn
and at least keep my chances live
although by the way that's actually
still at the reticle drop but the point
is firoozeh had a very brilliant way to
get stalemate with the move rook g5
check no matter how you take it the game
would have been a draw so a very tricky
little net there by firoozeh at the last
second
to bring us back here to the live for
but it but a very tricky ending their
nice defense by firoozeh with very
limited time on the clock and the kid is
back to singing there's the swoon Robert
and there's the answer we've been
looking for at b gol Z says 2650 is
actually the modern super day GM fifteen
hundred grandmasters in the world and
climbing being in the top 100 is elite
at incredible achievement I'm gonna let
you take that one and say whether you
agree or disagree if 2650 is the modern
day super GM a hard disagree I knew you
would that's why I let you have it go
for it extremely hard this year I think
the modern a super GM probably floats
somewhere in the twenty seven thirty
2740 was going to be my answer to we do
complete each other's sandwiches yeah
and we complete answers because let's
bring back the daily question just to
show everybody what it was and and the
reason we would disagree with that is
because really the point is it's getting
harder to be in the world's elite and a
super GM is supposed to define you know
the the unofficial title that belongs to
those guys who aren't just the GM but
competing in the top I would argue
thirty top 50 at least
and if you look at that the top fifty
usually is is at least above twenty
seven twenty most the time between
twenty seven thirty and twenty seven
forty is Robert would say so that was
gonna be my answer as well yes almost
really it's obviously very subjective
right what subject an answer and the
reason why I said twenty seven thirty to
forty is there are these interesting
players like Hari Krishna or Todd check
who are very strong players but aren't
quite piercing the top ten and not
particularly close at least not yet
and so I don't know where they fall in
but when you see Hari Krishna play in
the Shenzhen Masters where he beat
Dingley Ren and he's right he's in
tournament well if boy taschek is up to
twenty one to the world now so he's
right there okay but he's hovers in that
twenty seven thirty twenty seven fifty
range right I'm not sure I'm really not
sure and I would say that the top
players top ten players top 15 players
they have a different level they're just
part of the issue the grand chester
that's on the issue in terms of a bad
thing but complicating the question
is the Grantchester invites the top
players in the world and if they're not
invited are they the top you know super
GM's and that's an answer yeah okay well
um we we still have some time if you
want to give all the data questions see
a lot of people disagreeing with me what
else is new and that's okay
and but yeah I mean it's it's obviously
a subjective question but uh remind
everybody a big reason why we brought it
up is because all the residents just
cross 2700 for the first time today and
then that led to kind of a fun question
what leads to fun commentary is when you
get a whole bunch of guys like that
together playing in the Paris rapid and
blitz and so join us tomorrow at 6 a.m.
Pacific time something in the CET GMT
world but you know I don't do math and
be with us as we cover the Paris rapid
and blitz right here on twitch.tv slash
chess so all right Robert still a two
game two games spread here in this match
still a lot of chess to be played the
storyline Robert keeps being that no one
has overcome a three-game lead to win at
JSC C match yet Robert but if there's
one storyline that might suggest that be
done it would be a match like this where
we know how much faroush is a monster
and bullet right so I think you know
this is uh gonna have us all on the edge
of our seat for the rest today
yeah actually the time situation right
here version is up a minute and he's
probably gonna play f4 and just kick
this night of the center opposite color
bishops interesting dynamic the bishop
um b3 much better than the counterpart
on g7 today to me indicates a clear
advantage for the white pieces and he
took back this pawn in d3 so now it's
even material but just bring the knight
back ninety three if you trade Knights
you're not getting closer to a draw some
people think obstacles mean a draw look
at the situation the Bishop III is a
monster an absolute monster is d6
hanging was d6 hanging well he could
have taken it but he was worried about
something overwhelming on f4 baby but no
I think you're right the Queen could
have taken d6 I'm been guarding both f4
and d1 so I mean this is almost five
years b5 Queen g6 ideas are six ideas
even even a crazy ideas positionally
banker because it seems to take g5 and
then as I as I called that he takes you
five and doubles on the FL cuz your
opposite code Bishop coming to life
right yes this is this is gonna be
really hard for a way you did offend
already looks honestly just he's he's
dead he really is what are you gonna do
here you have seven is under attack your
rookie seven you just go to work at 5:00
and go after the g5 on and then you wake
up five we have three just take it
there was takes just just play Bishop
takes then swing this Queen over to h5
and let's go said you should have C to
at any moment right so he could have
gone to h7 Square yeah like we said the
F file would be there okay I think just
queen of three was good too but rook g5
has maybe even strong oh wait Queen h6
we need for it is that he's Queen D for
24 oh my god Purusha of lean back and
like he went full om Jesus Nazi mode
nobody it was still a blunder because
look now way he has much better drawing
chances getting the Queen's off the
board was not what he wanted love that
move get forth to g4 and now you go from
G to f5 you can choose do you see a five
I like it better you like you better I
like it better yeah right I want it that
way tell me why yes you nailed it I love
you so much we are pop culture soulmates
and you know it oh my gosh G 4G 5g six
going right for it here we go here we go
not g6 yet sleep he was king out
somewhere or play a four a five cement
yep white squares over there something
anything came but again though there's
no denying that Brooke g5 was a blunder
from the idea we were highlighting with
Queen f3 Queen eighty-five earlier cuz
way he has better chances to hold this
Queens off the board this is there's a
reason ferocious time is kind of slowly
getting closer to equal yep so now it's
just a matter of technique so does he
play for B 3 a 4 and B 4
keep but I'm asking okay this answered
my question I'm asking where's the beef
even if you get that because like you
put the King on a better square put the
pawn on a better square like this is why
the attack of ox coefficients was so
much more dangerous there's no clear
plan for Purusha to convert here goes qh
v upon g6 okay he's gonna go for it he's
trying to sit tight where's Vaughn light
squares okay I don't mind that at all
now you can play G's okay I like that
now you put g6 and lock that Bishop in
that was a mistake
yep in fact here comes blacks Brooke
getting active as long as he does get
made it Brooks coming to e8 rookie that
was me that was me there should be six
one the exchange he didn't do that
either okay but he finally finds a way
in alright Wow Purusha does convert he
brings this thing to a one-game match
and we are gonna have fire down the
stretch here for sure but but wow that
that almost got away from him yeah no
this is this is now a one-point match
and I think this is what frozen needs
but as soon as he touched this down to
one game we said going to the bullet one
or two games
that's the comfort zone for fruga he
knows he's a better bullet player but as
you said earlier way he he's been pretty
tough opponent in the bullets segments
of surprisingly cell right yeah he's
been he's doing quite good as that time
controlled windle's okay well now we've
got some theory to make a card proud
well what's this whites of a pawn
yeah but Knight g4 is coming yeah maybe
night
86 to b4 to see two as an idea of course
that's there's 94 1993 here ah 93 but if
route d3 you're taking g7 is that your
point
absolutely okay okay I'm just checking
on your on your tactics over there big
guy okay the night h3 can be played or
night a3 if you're in the guarding c2
before this night pops into one of these
squares yeah so Knight c3 allows room c1
just a converse it to okay
but I was worried about the bishop
following a 5 but I guess white would
have efore as long as there's a knight
on c3 so everything seems to be held
right now for Wei Yi is he's just gonna
get out of Dodge with a clean pawn that
he stole on e5 looks like it because
that's a Knight e5 you just go Bishop g2
and that's the great Bishop as well so
what cruiser needs here is to somehow
place c6 and just hope that the extra
pawn is there nothing this we start
trading some pieces and you're not lost
this looks terrible
whoa wrecker roca Deline i all snap here
comes e3 I don't think Ferrucci
anticipated that when he's getting some
counter play still yeah but I'm gonna
get that Bishop out of here I want I
want f4 and and g4 if you bishop e4 then
f3
we're just leaning in because he's like
where's my mate but it's not there I
mean look this key side for white there
knots kind of awkward yeah yeah I agree
this is Swiss cheese all around I don't
even be hungry aw dude I made Rubens
last night for the kids
you're such a good dad you can say
anything that no I just stop it tell me
more about me do you enjoy Rubens our ad
ad ad ad meal 85 coming we think I like
it
g5 like we said I know you don't want me
to mention the Swiss cheese but those
are some holes yeah in black is happy to
start putting some ponies in you got to
go to c2 because d3 i trade and pick up
f3 Oh or take but still g5 is coming I
think oh gosh bad lights for a mission
up against some nice yeah this night
belongs on this score but it's difficult
because white White's gonna try at some
point to unwind these things and get
this Bishop out you know so you got you
got to lock down the holes what you can
yeah like we're doing an h1 where's it
going you don't want to go root G one
that doesn't smell a pawn h4 yeah there
you answered it right a
for h5 but then she finds I was gonna
say I've loved h6 right shut it down
just like no soup for you this is a very
common positional approach you'll play
h5 everybody the point is you okay
unless he just wants to try to win the
pawn okay he takes it to try to win the
pawn but normally that little pawn duo
there allows you to close up regardless
of what break they take and it's very
very nice defensive technique yeah no
mortgage for played to allow for f4
finally getting that on finally I
actually think it was I think he should
have played age five I think this was a
mistake by Purusha yeah I don't disagree
I don't hear it play at for Bishop h3
freezing to try to get his 19 to d4 but
look at the Queen side pawn do you start
trading yeah
these are trading for white then the
Queen set pawns are just fallen and game
so it looks really really nice unlike
the other games we've seen in three oh
right now we've got a an edge for away
Yi on the clock so this is not um not
comfy territory where you looking to
strike back and keep a two-game lead as
we as we inch our way to bullet eighteen
minutes left here in the three-minute
segment yep now this is this looks like
how much is it 18 minutes left so I'm
trying to figure out match strategy for
both players here if you are way you
want as many games in the three-minute
as possible if you're firoozeh do you
just use all of your time and keep the
game's goings that you get closer and
closer to bullet yep and if you're our
stats guy you love to see those dancing
heads because it means we have a close
match the snake the swivel yeah that is
it was funny especially the one where
they're overlapping to each other so is
this a draw Robert to the outsider and
no it should not be a draw because if
you look at the Queen side here comes a
3-2 yeah a3 kicks that naive wins the c6
pawn but the real key here is that the
Queen side pawns are so weak for black
there see phones are double and isolated
the a pawn means a king b2 King 83 King
a4 at some moment could be in the cards
this is also such a butcher move because
it's like I actually don't need to do
anything
everything is held the Knights are
struggling for active squares you could
even go full king walk to f2 to guard
the bishop go to g3 this is that's over
that's a move that really frustrates
your opponent when they prove they can
play something like that it's funny he
went to go to the say he wanted to do
this originally but the knight would
have come with check so the reason he
played a3 now is is exactly because of
the combo we're seeing and way Eve
showing showing why 2740 is the super GM
range right now this is over this is
definitely over and Davis it's funny
because I was saying before how the
white king could sneak up the Queen side
he says you said did a very mature thing
running the King the Kings had to close
down the only active piece for black and
secure the victory oh hey that's me just
send me a message and I'll give you a
diamond membership buddy hashtag you're
welcome HS TV chat I see almost 10,000
of you whether you're watching this at
twitch.tv slash
chest chest comm TV hit that purple
Follow button tomorrow we go live with
grand chessboard coverage the juniors
features championship final actually the
date depends on who wins this match
don't want to reveal that but I can tell
you that we worked really hard with
these top eally players and working
around a very busy twenty nineteen
calendar so if wayy wins it'll be a
different date than if furusho wins
which is why we haven't announced it yet
for those wondering so okay well that
means they'll have good news the end of
the match because they'll have a date to
circle and put in their calendar to call
that it works sake to tell you know tell
everybody in their family that they
can't go to the nice lunch that's being
hosted because they better plans I'm not
even gonna respond to that that's great
well maybe you can go to that lunch and
I can find myself a new co commentator
my jokes your jokes are great and I love
them touchdown all right see what do you
think about this position is that I
think it's a it's a position that
Fabiana would love boring no i'm getting
to sleep on you me take it no but
there's Bishop g5 tricks you got to be
careful
my bishop is going to eat three
we see five bring the bishop to see
three okay he goes for it I I kind of
liked that Bishop on that dagger but I'm
a sucker for g7 you know that I'm the
school of the austere Sarah wanna free
pawns of free pawn free pawns are free
pawn I mean just looks like a pretty
free pawn all things considered any I'm
not even joking I literally almost buy
coffee I would you said that you gotta
be me and Robert are working together be
careful before you take a drink of
anything because you never know what's
coming out of these mouths next all
right
rook d8 he's gonna trade and play Bishop
III okay pawn notwithstanding it's Dobbs
code Bishop game I'm gonna guess I'm
gonna make a bold prediction Robert this
game let's mark it right now this game
takes seven minutes more off the total
game clock a full seven minutes from now
we will still be on this game actually
it's not good news if he doesn't win it
because it sounds good bishops right
right message maybe not maybe just
getting the clock down so we can get to
bullet as a ferocious strategy but this
game is gonna be a long ways away here
as fruta tries to convert on that extra
pawn yeah not the question is what's the
best defensive setup for black because
some people say Chevrolet we're gonna EA
to go in the active open file or ship
whom I work on d8 to challenge the pawn
the rook ID it doesn't make sense
because if you put the rook on d8 white
is already going to protect that pawn
anyway so then what's your work doing
there now after Bishop f4 adjourned ago
Bishop d6 and runs an EA to claim that
open file but there is Ricky I like that
yeah I think that was a pretty
instructive moment but now for white
what I would consider doing is not
pushing a piece of c4 we're playing c3
and to get my king to c4 yeah very nice
point it allows me to go c3 d4 and some
things like that and challenge that PO
instruction or whether you can't if you
push up on this and for example you do
not want to lock down the position
completely you are a mama bird feeding
us baby birds I just got my mouth open
for knowledge here I love that you are
feeding us mama bird that c3 King
popping up and the point is that Roberts
creating even if it's not objectively a
winning plan right if computers were
playing the point is that he's
creating the most opportunities for your
opponent to go wrong and I think a lot
of people sometimes forget that that's
how a lot of grandmasters win game is
right Robert you got to put your
opponent's in opportunities to make
mistakes it's not always about the most
concrete forced wind whether it because
it may not exist right yeah so I really
love Roberts very flexible plan there to
bring the king up try for B for well he
goes D six what does he calculate it oh
he's got a crank ideas yep so I think
the bishop guarding h7 I think we
shouldn't Ruki one check but you can
still do by the way rook e1 check we
trade rugs d7 Bishop a5 but no no if
Brooke II won't trade bishops I play c3
but then you have King f8 exactly one
King okay I thought I could trap your
bishop in a creative way but I think
that's better okay he went does I don't
like that well now here comes rook d1
wait maybe I can go rook t1 wasn't
Bishop a4 than d7 okay so he's still
getting d7 and and the point is that now
the rook is very much tied down and we
have rooks on the board still I feel
like that gives white more chances to
are you showing that he's showing that
classy defense he done he knows that a
pawn is less relevant than whether he
can deal with the passer right and again
I think that's super instructive to see
how these guys are very patient they're
all they're looking for and I think
common mistakes are made in games people
get too greedy with a pawn rather than
realizing it's not how many points you
have it's who's gonna get a queen first
or cause other problems because of the
threat of getting a queen right and I'm
this Bishop a4 idea even g3c gained a
tempo on this Bishop and close down the
vision from the h2 pawn because if the
rooks get written d7 the issue pond
would be under attack and so that was an
interesting way to do this that problem
is now is does he does he just trade
okay he has to go for B 7 because Bishop
a5 would have been met by cheese 6 and
f5 so loved it it should be fine that's
a beautiful piece now the king wants to
run to c4 like earlier and if black can
replace C for that pawns on a light
square and I gladly keep on check so I
think it Ricky one check now as possible
but I don't something like King a 2 can
be three teams e4 that's my first idea
right so what we're doing is here King
d6 king d6 there could be c4 with made
threats but then rookies
would be fine so whoa going out this way
huh
okay they're just cookies six check
coming yeah sings great where's your
king going good aji father go Bishop f3
and punish for me I love that I think
that's about to not have three and then
h4 is coming so the question is do you
go f4 check or just Bishop f3 they
should have three threatening it and
there's no mate
Purusha is like he's biting his knuckles
I feel I feel the pain he wants he wants
h4 and g4 and mate stuff but the king is
getting out
I just think practically it's so hard to
defend this position for black your dad
great your king is in no-man's land
way he is giving a valiant effort here
that's a nice move if rook takes c5 king
of four comes with tempo so you force
the trade now he'll play Bishop d6
blocking off the rook yep ladies move
pawn to g3 with the F pawn because what
black one is at some point and try to
get a past punt for himself like yeah
for the H file yo oh he was trying to go
for Bishop East to be checked in
I agree that peruses than a great job
keeping it flexible pushing but you got
to give wayy credit for being down on
time for a long time yeah and now play
you knew the drives to not run to
Brooke up to the tempo and now looks
like key
I guess can't you look at to come oh
he's gonna get the Brooks off the board
I don't think Virgil wants that no and
here's why even ugly move at work a5 but
a necessary move now the bishop and go
to see for there were gonna be five
things of that nature
and it's that rook gonna get traffic
better be careful you take on up six now
morning oh he goes for it is there
enough winning chances here though he's
officially up on the clock
you play a five-way there it is at five
minutes and five and f4o he doesn't do
it no he doesn't do it for it probably
cuz chief or but again if this game ends
in a draw remember I made a prediction
with 14 minutes left that this game
would take seven minutes off the clock
yeah they both have no time right now so
if someone loses on time don't be too
full but right now look at the h8 square
that's the big problem is that yep I
just has to sacrifice the bishop and the
a pawn for the a and B pawns and run the
King back to the Kings side that's why
they agreed for a draw
okay six minutes came off the clock so I
guess I was wrong but pretty close to
the to the truth that that game firoozeh
so who does that favor right way he
defended a bad position forever and
showed that he wasn't gonna be bullied
in time pressure psychological edge but
Ferrucci gets his way closer to bullet
where most people feel this is where the
match really becomes gets you know the
match is really on right that was a big
win for way there as you said you know
if you're gonna spin all that time you
need to win a game but I still think
being within two games in the book I
almost think Rouge is the favorite but I
think he's a two game bullet that's
where I'll put well our stats would say
that he's a three game bullet favorite
so I know you I know you love
disagreeing with the smarter chess
predictions but they're right there with
you to say that firoozeh is about a
three game favorite in the bullet format
and so you know in theory that would
mean this game right here is one of the
biggest in the match right right now
because if this ends up being the last
three minute game just way ye you know
get to give himself a cushion or does
Purusha
you know really take the driver's seat
when the predictions also said five to
four in the five minute portion for
frisia and i'm hanging three minutes I
don't like to point out where
predictions are wrong Robert hey come on
selective statistics the smarter chess
predictions are known to be and retained
handcuffed in a basement where he just
gives us his opinion that's full of
people have started saying since the
last match but that's not actually true
by the way Andrew tang is safe I hope so
the Penguins ever entertain actually did
Saturday yesterday for the fan the
subscribers here to our chest Channel we
appreciate that hope you had fun with
with the tank gang so your we have we
going for this like summer oxy vine
because it's not a Sicilian or black so
the c-pawn weight as a free piece wait
is it quit TG for free piece what am I
missing all you guys just like he just
went what did I do
cuz c5 doesn't win a piece he just
missed I think he thought c5 was gonna
win it back but it allows Knight b5
oh I think he thought his vision was he
protected his night energy for he flew
back in his chair I lost my bleep you
Robert blink twice if everything's okay
I'm okay but I don't think he's okay
he's so mad I won't he should be he just
be just completely blood her but at
least he shows us how he really feels I
mean this is what do you what do you
think he's saying yeah I was gonna say
wait he doesn't seem too thrilled I
don't know a lay his resting chess face
is really going the extra mile here
today
okay match strategy time Robert okay if
firoozeh is answering the question I was
gonna ask you do you just let the clock
go and try to get yourself two bullet so
you can take a break recover
psychologically he's going to the
bathroom I think faroush is answering
that question by saying that's exactly
what I'm gonna do but wait can someone
give way yeast some coffee I mean I feel
like all the Red Bull went to Turkey
someone gave way a little pick-me-up
over there but wow I see water in the
corner over there you see that this
bottle well if this ends up being a
match Robert if your prediction is right
and firoozeh only makes up two games and
bullet and way he ends up winning by a
game that might be the moment of the
match right there honestly with that
Knight g4 inexplicable blunder yeah I
you were talking and I was looking at
the board and I'm like 94 that that's a
blunder that's just a free piece there
and as smarter chess is making jokes
he's saying someone just told firoozeh
that Robert said he's only a two-game
favorite and bullets eddie freaked out
okay well he resigns that was not our
last three minute game because of a
blunder I'm gonna make a bold prediction
that this one is so there's still a
chance to bring it within two but okay
if this gets worse somehow he loses this
game and he's down for now we're really
we're really coming back to that moment
so yeah that was that was really bad but
he goes right back to this Petroff here
with the Bushman before as well he's
hoping for c5 again I promise you we did
not enjoy the end game yeah I was gonna
say
we did not mean to give up that pawn
blunder but that's what's so frustrating
when if your Cruiser like my opponent
blunder I had a dominant endgame and I
didn't win and I would spend a lot of
time trying and then I blunder
immediately in the next game yep that's
the tilt that's a form of tilt for sure
it's like a micro tails micro tilt not
to be confused with macro tilt or just
thanks for completing mine
yeah well if you are one of the nearly
ninety five hundred members with us
right now please don't go anywhere
because I think that would you
regretting that decision on a Sunday
because I think we're gonna be in for
some white-knuckle chess here in the
bullet portion firoozeh as much as he's
kind of regretting the way the last few
minutes have gone I don't think this
match is over at all so thank you for
being here and it carves in the chat car
was in the chat I don't know how it went
today in Paris but I can only hope that
it was a good day for mr. Nakamura he
said that way is the bomb way he is the
bomb but he also says that firoozeh the
big favorite and bullet and I think we
would agree so this match is is gonna be
exciting here we don't have we don't
have much more time to know whether ye
can hold his own and bullet the mystery
will soon be answered and let's take a
look at this position Danny because I
don't like the fact that blacks pawn is
on f5 yep awkward scenario where black
squares for a little bit loose just play
after we here for white there yeah he
plays it quickly this is where fruit is
at its best it's got a speed up ya plate
g4 I don't even know why I just do it g4
actually looks good you know you submit
offhandedly as like a whatever
no g4 actually is a good idea to play
what f3 couldn't be taken because f5 and
the bishop would have been pinned to e8
so I was just trying to create counter
play but now white is gonna take the
slower approach and fight for the e-file
yeah okay but where you can well you can
can fight that fight yeah now Queen d4
doesn't do anything I was trying to get
my queen over to the king side between
e4 Queenie v perhaps just offering a
queen I'll actually be careful about
that because if I poke 25 and we trade
the rook e1
my e and f five pawns are both
polynomials I can't just do exactly what
I want
unfortunately yeah I mean as much as he
went back for this one very quickly
especially maybe he wanted to get
another good endgame if we remember the
way he blundered into that endgame
Robert I'm kind of questioning this
decision as your last chance to get a
win in three minute cuz I don't know if
this is gonna give white a ton of fight
here I don't know Queen III maybe but
put for some counter play but maybe I'm
wrong maybe Queen e3 g3 and you got to
be careful about rook e1 I like 23 I was
like Queen c6 both both moves going for
pawns that are weak in white skin we see
six goes left your c4 as well which is
an added benefit and after Queen c6 if
you had g3 I could even consider like
Queen g2 at some moment just
infiltrating yeah I like that that was
my idea with Queenie e3 was to maybe put
her on f2 but same idea where you taking
time here but this is um me 7 of all the
moves of all the moves
Queenie 7 like that just seems the most
passive and unnecessary and King Fe yeah
what is he thinking he's like I don't
know I'm super confused what's going on
here he really wants for Russia to play
rook e1 so we can play rook e6 right
baiting him into the simplification cuz
that 5 home will be hanging if not for
their work and e1 hanging in that
scenario so and D 2 which is Queen e1
check kind of things as a suspicious
looking idea rook f1 Bishop g4 Bishop g4
guards f5 which maybe maybe allows that
rook to go to e6 indeed it does that's
what he plays and
I mean d5 now I'm like there he goes
f5 s hanging a check yeah King f8 is
feeling the feel of the breeze gets the
rooks off the board but way this is
definitely bad for blood yeah I'm a
little worried about the decision made
there I mean you know this goes to an
end game it's gonna be bad for black
because it looks like that white King
might eventually go at pawn before king
b3 and
g4 it's out of the picture yeah and if
you're okay you could take f5 because in
the end of those lines you still guard
c2 there's no threat I also play queen
c6 here right about 57 give me all your
queen sized balls I don't like taking a
five because you know if you take I get
to check and it just feels like but
maybe maybe the Queen ending doesn't
offer the most winning chances so firuze
just trying to come up with more I do
like your move Bishop f5 it seems like
the most simplistic and I'm somewhat
concerned if I go Queen c6 am I giving
away h2 and g3 and I was worried about
ideas like Bishop d1 or Bishop e2 but I
guess King b2 would just solve the c2
pawn so yeah b4 okay you know what I
like about that is now in any
simplification there's this outdoor idea
where white runs the King via a four to
c6 and wins a king upon ending so you
just you open up this this chance of
winning in a very very massive trade for
sure know that King in the ending idea
is very important to note because the c7
pawn is the real target here and let's
see right now what is what you're doing
is twenty seconds it took the pawn so
now takes it now I think we'll see it oh
he goes for Queen a8 he's gonna walk the
King up he's not seated here yep take c7
okay but g3 falls c7 Falls you would
guess this has to be good for white
because white is getting too many things
with Czech Queen c7 or Queen somewhere
seven I don't matter but for take me six
now see if you take them before c5 my
white all very nice and that opens up
the bishop there for the king when you
trying to laugh in the face of danger
but let's not forget who Simba is that's
firoozeh Tori nice motor up Oh Queen d5
check that we defy check saves
everything and very quick and nice
calculation by perugia and look at this
Queen on d3 it covers g3 crow 6 but
attacks f5 with check if you play g6
here which he just did King King
somewhere do we go for the walk you know
I want it if I go Kim Beach
Queen d4 check I don't know how this
pawn in the game is I don't think you
can get away with that you're thinking
you win the H pawn on the outside but
protect it pass people and make them
make me a little nervous
so Queen c3 here how does that work okay
time pressure commences yeah there's
white kings on getting out of this cutie
checks black and play Queen e1 here
event Queen if Queen LOI trades
whoa what is he saying he's saying
there's no way to break through it it's
a draw well can't we go for g4 at some
point yeah what yeah and if you play h5
there's there's the king coming on to g2
h3 h4 before now it wins because you
straight off the pot you're gonna win
last you win the H fun I think what you
just blundered this he thought he was
going into a drawn king upon ending but
we are gonna be heading into bullet with
a two-game lead instead because that was
a massive blunder
let me show everybody I'll back up on
this main board here and just show
everybody what happened there Wei Yi
with a massive massive Miss evaluation
really not a miscalculation here after
Queen to c2 he looked at the squares and
thought there was no way in for the
white king but he underestimated the
journey and then g4 which as Robert
pointed out changes the pawn structure
and creates an Avenue in so but he had
just played so well Robert any other
move by Wei Yi whether Queen e1 or Queen
e3 it's hard to it's hard to see
firoozeh winning this endgame right
besides time pressure
yeah this was a huge blunder that past
b-pawn was annoying your queen e3 moved
probably queen g2 scared him a little
bit something like that I'm totally with
you simplifying into a bad endgame as
you know earlier day that past b5 Han
told the tale and to strong victory for
firoozeh
all right well wow we have we it was a
huge victory we have a huge match ahead
a two-game lead for Wei ease we headed a
bullet but before we go to break we have
another Photoshop coming our way it's
been an inverting Photoshop day
I I made the mo I made the point that
usually we get full Fabiano people
leaning in all we get to see is their
forehead and fro and it with firoozeh we
have the opposite but when Fabiana when
firoozeh become
what we have Bobby Bobby Russa and
that's Robert Hess that's Rob Rob ruha
Holley that's all he has I like it
Ollie hats all right well we are gonna
take our last break before the gloves
really come off this has been a thriller
all day I'm upset it's gonna be over in
about a half hour but you shouldn't go
anywhere your Sunday chest day is not
done yet we'll be back in just a few
moments
[Music]
oh man I'm bored protests League regular
season is over it's hot outside what am
I gonna do I'll tell you he's gonna sign
up with the other protest League super
fans and play and the first-ever fans
summer series now you can team up with
the world's top chess players join other
users like gold dust or e MC Adil chess
for Andrea botas Muscato a7 Helms knight
and others are already competing
actively for their favorite pro chess
league teams every week the PCL summer
series is a first of its kind event
where fans like you play alongside pro
chests stars like Youngblood big hammer
Sam Shanklin jord Meir Mubarak Obion and
Eric Hansen fans from two PCL teams play
against each other every Saturday
through the month of August and $1,000
in cash is up for grabs - the most
active and best performing fans but one
of them be you the pro chesley summer
Series championship awaits those brave
enough to take on the world's top chess
players so what are you waiting for get
in on the action today by going to
protest league calm / summer series
click on the club logo of your favorite
teams sign up and start playing of
course make sure you tune in and watch
all the action at twitch.tv slash chess
chess calm TV and see who takes home
summer glory
and we are back now with the jr. speech
Chess Championship and but right before
Bullock get started give everybody their
last chance to get involved in social
media make clips - if you want we do
have our moment of the match maybe your
clip will be chosen so have fun with
that
but our daily question we get a response
here Robert that says I think it should
actually be a combination of 2700 plus
plus major tournament wins which kind of
takes our daily question to the next
level if you remember what it was
everybody our daily question is what
defines a super GM that's actually
suggesting maybe we want a super GM
title right because the way people get
norms is by a combination of raiding and
tournament performance so I'm just gonna
use that tweet to ask you Robert do you
think we ever get a super GM title and
chess yes or no yeah I think it's
actually quite likely because really the
more grandmasters there are the more
kind of makes you know we talk about
players being stronger than you look at
the ratings but I do like the idea of
having more incentives once you become a
GM of course you want to become world
champion right having title norms to
keep you going is also sudden I think
you'll be motivated by and sometimes
that 2600 GM as a 2750 performance and
they gain rating and maybe that could be
some sort of norm of some sort I think
okay I'm surprised by that answer I
didn't I I would vote that fee day
probably never goes down that route
because of the name Grandmaster and what
that signifies it's such a transcendent
thing outside of chess you say you're a
grandmaster or something people know do
we really want to add confusion to that
but I I loved the debate that's
interesting websites that's right well
here we go here we go we have the bullet
portion we have a great match still have
8,000 of you with us thanks for being
here this has been quite the thriller if
you are somehow at this point not a
follower of the chess channel don't make
that a you problem fix that problem on
this Sunday and hit that purple follow
button let's fix the let's fix the the
games here to get them started here
let's do this thing I'm ready no more no
more waiting I'm ready for a bullet
Roberts ready
he's got sandwiches on the brain I do so
let's get this going - I love it so here
we go let's go let's go I
conserve most of my energy to see all
the ranges 3301 bullet rating 3301
Hikaru Nakamura licks his lips
especially if erosion gains anymore of
that and this is what we've all been
waiting for
canned the one seed in the bracket wayy
hold his own 965 is that a thing
that's the thing I'm so confused I was
just a piece sack I guess you can't
protect both nights and break the pin at
the same time that was ridiculous
Purusha paused and wondered if it was a
thing - because he's down on the time
which is rare for bullet for him he
decides to just go for this one D take
c3 are you i guess the council quickly
that's easier for bullet gotta be happy
when you see way use connection there
are four bars in the fastest portion you
know that he's happy with that stable
stabilization may be plugged himself
hardwired in old-school style
what full 90s right went to dial up
never go full 90's never go full 90
that's true all right we've got a pawn
that way you somehow did steel and seems
okay to have it it's it's a cc pawn but
it's it's still a pawn and what use now
gonna try to work and undoes if you
capture it'll take back with the C pawn
here I think it played Queens for G to
Queens you for Bishop c4 same kind of
thing Queen she - I like them this is
getting okay now Bishop I wanted to go
Bishop f3 but it was wrong this feels
like a lot of compensation for black
especially in bullet where now the time
is the time is writing is far it's the
ship is writing itself as far as the
storyline that we expect with Wei Yi
down on the clock
yeah but the position was great for
white your two pawns here I just have
ones of variants he's gonna play Brooke
d4 place it before I can highlight it
force he's trying to chase that Bishop
around and make an exchange
look these bishops right these III e4
Bishop's looking great hitting b7 if you
play these six I can sit my bishop on c6
oh I love the way we use played this I
agrees
for those of you just joining us there
were several very wild time scrambles
even in the longer portions where wayy
for the most part has held his own and
that's got all of us wondering what's
gonna happen in Bullitt here
oh we know Ferrucci is among the
trickiest which means three threaten me
for first we would have been met by
Bishop g2 but yeah 45 look at the extra
pawns right the it's I see the e pawn CC
pond yeah we've got Bishop g2 for sure
rook takes e5 oh gosh no you take or do
you play Brooke at 500 games if the rook
had taken there was mate on f1 man that
was a rough he's still got still got
checkmate threats coming if he can find
a safe square I think he's gonna get it
rookie for just take look at that now
black has the most you have a pawn rook
g4 chess rook c4 if your wayi
how do you simplify this because you
don't want to get grinded out here in
the time scramble give me them
Rudy for a check back take on c2 it's a
free pawn playing tickle first put the
Bishop Bishop on an undefended square
baby
rook g5 you're saying okay what you won
White will probably play C for de no I
thought it was c4 to defend the bishops
to that start you v e5 q g6 you protect
your c5 p v6 and the Brooke is out of
play yeah if I'm only move it oh he
plays c3 but now see three is gonna fall
with check thank you okay to do what he
doesn't bullet right now where you know
the check was bad he could have played
h4 maybe made it a little harder but
he's hoping for some sort of last minute
counter play oh we've seen this story
before we've seen this story before
where wayy went for a last minute King
walk for a mating net and note the h1
square match to the bishop so yep you
can't trade off rooks
oh okay but you have to be very careful
here the King got itself in a tricky
position King d6 and rook h8 is a threat
yep some flavor Volusia doesn't know
what to do he's taking time here comes
King bees good move kini 6:46 check King
ones are running the King style
well yeah but White's also got an eye on
the pawns right now and they're stuck
they are stuck you're right
Bishop c4 way ease and it's twice now
swindled his way into a very complicated
endgame by the time to any a lot of time
five minutes the H pawns falling this
firoozeh almost tired of getting
swindled by wayy who would have thought
in bullet che now he's got okay King g5
also worked as the pawn was pinned but
he brings the King back to D six were
kept six okay okay I think we're gonna
see a perpetual to end this game because
I don't think firoozeh wants anymore
nope I'm wrong okay but way he says
alright that was you think that was a
bad decision right there I think oh my
gosh you're wasting time is for nobody I
disagree I think that he might get a win
now
no way you don't think so no chance you
know you've seen stranger things
I mean also season three now out here by
stranger things but we we've seen that
we've seen stranger things that someone
losing one of these end games i I don't
know I don't think that was necessary
for way you to go for that I think it's
a waste of time and if you think about
an expected return like expected value
here I think if you're version you just
gave this game over with another bag
Rieman look how much time you just
wasted wowzers wells there's wow there's
the next game gets underway we're back
to the Petroff and i maybe you're right
we only have one bullet game in the
books and nearly seven minutes went off
the clock so the fact that firoozeh
didn't get a win there you know time is
a-ticking right you still think there's
plenty of time given given how good of a
bullet player you are if you're if
you're in ferocious camp but you're
you're running out of opportunities to
prove it are we impressed by how way ye
has handled these time scrambles at this
point absolutely
he's so resourceful defensively the guys
just the admirable technique there and
right now Perugia has what 20 minutes 20
minutes left to to get to victory well
not gonna be easy
okay firoozeh better again in this
position we've now seen them play a few
times but he hasn't converted a full
point yet in this line has he know he
can run that endgame remember that was a
bad wait 25 we talked about this exact
position taking working one I talked to
a position earlier so wait he repeated
the line and just now is down upon it's
so weird yeah I don't really understand
I'm gonna be honest yeah he again out of
the opening stage he has consistently
been so like really since the beginning
of the match where where ye went up
three oh he hasn't I mean he's obviously
won a lot of games and he's in in the
driver's seat but the openings have have
been subpar here ya never be a checkmate
Verbier Chad did you just miss that yep
or doodle scoodle because we have a one
game match I don't understand why you
decision to repeat that opening that was
a really bad choice because in the last
game he blundered in the end game which
at that point is hold a ball but we
liked White's position thought the
majority of that game but and if there
was a recipe to fix the fact that you
played a seven minute game and didn't
win in the first one you win that next
one in about 90 seconds faroush Annelle
only down one game so we are we are
gonna come down to the wire and now I
would say momentum is definitely in
ferocious corner absolutely you don't
see momentum in the corner next to the
water bottle and the banana over there
are you eyeing some food while you see
Momentum's in the in his corner looking
that's right hey I'm sorry I'm sorry
you know I messed up I messed up it's
okay I forgive you alright this is this
is getting really exciting I wait we've
now we're now back to this kind of g3
King's Indian I believe we saw this
earlier in the day but AG for a young
appease earlier oh that's right that's
what we saw at 94 first you just plotted
a piece okay didn't do that here so you
know that's a start
before played right now way II is only
down ten seconds so I guess if he can
outplay him and stay within that range
you'd be happy but this is excellent
here yeah I don't yeah he's got it great
that's what I mean if you can help that
White's position is great but c5 was a
weird move this totally unnecessary yeah
if forcing blacks hand but in a dynamic
way that didn't have to move yet it
literally opened the D file blacks
biggest weakness in the structure
normally the d6 pawn there was a strange
decision to change that structure okay
he's pointing out everybody that the
Queen can't take c5 because f6 falls so
that's kind of the key point of why he
can go for it and now he might he might
switch 56 but you got to worry about
your own discoveries here take that
thing take it Sackett do it love it
there's an e5 for key mode at the end
maybe Oh Queen six g7 3-piece g7 free
piece free exchange version
whispering sweet nothings those aren't
curse words kids those are just sweet
nothings if you can read lips times
because I can read lips I've been deaf
my whole life so rare times he curses in
English and I made it out and I was like
okay yeah that's how he sounds his voice
when he curses he goes full Mickey Mouse
okay surrounding the pawn rook b7 Knight
moves you've got c6 notice the bishop
guards the c-4 square that makes c7 or
real threat wait c7 no you can't move
any further okay but you can play Brooke
b6 yeah he does it nice you okay now
rook III yeah Perugia gets full credit
ease down the exchange but he's
definitely making this tricky so Bishop
a six I guess just 96 back woo-taek
takes e4 just take it play Bishop e6
back in Brookes III do it
Dandy's totally fine yeah take it okay
in the end white can take twice on be
free I don't think he saw that man just
missed his chance firoozeh might have
just oh no this is fine
oh he's okay yes nothing but a bunch of
trades yeah
now there's Bishop anywhere besides me
okay okay if your wayi you want to get
another two minutes out of this game
yeah but you needed that victory because
you would been up two games you only
have one now this is totally true this
isn't draw only this is where firoozeh
does his best right as someone just said
he's super slippery super tricky what
you were waiting to keep playing is he's
smart
yeah waste more time he's up on the
clock to which the problem is that
firuze you can pre move with the night
from now until Kingdom Come right you
know literally no moves he can't pre
move almost night-night somewhere back
to f5 Knights somewhere back to f5
removes gaining a little bit of time on
the clock every time time after time 5
and again so where we at in the game
clock we've got 17 minutes this is not
going to be a make-or-break game of the
match regardless but like you said Wei
Yi lets a victory slip but he also gets
a few more minutes off the clock if
you're trying to stop the runaway train
that is Olly Reza firoozeh and the
bullet portion so that was a loss for
way though yeah I'm with you and again
especially he's gonna keep going back to
this opening I'm gonna agree that not
not a huge fan of his decision to to
take on kind of a clearly worse position
and one that has has led to some ok he's
actually only -1 and in this position
total in the match if I'm doing my math
right but if he should have lost a
couple other games yeah I mean it's been
looking on wait o g7 wasn't hanging with
cows like we've seen this before but I
for a second does equate a pawn and look
at the car in the chat why it is where
you keep doing this I keep asking the
same question it doesn't good for black
and a very very strange decision if
he goes for the same line with the Queen
on e5 and blunders the pawn again I'm
calling uncle I'm Uncle like stop it you
know Queen III here though now he takes
a second and he's not gonna plunder the
same pawn twice so it's just the same
thing keep doing it but be fair my king
me to play fun it shows the difference I
mean guys who know bullish strategy like
a car oh and I think this is where
someone like wait doesn't have the same
experience this is just too passive not
the right psychological position to put
yourself in in bullet chess so you know
but sometimes the OTB
stronger guys you don't have as much
experience and bullet don't have those
kind of moments of clarity like hey I
need to change it up and they just keep
going for it thinking objectively in a
classical game I would defend this
position as black but that's not what
you want to do not at all and White's
position is just more space we tell my
double pawns people say wait why does
these double seat pawns you must be
worse no but way is more control over
the board and if your Queen never goes
to e5 is proponent for pawn g3 my bishop
on d3 is a great piece your bishop on g6
is not so hot so I really like White's
position and pretty much all of these
endings that we've seen and looking for
h4 this but actually blacks of 10
seconds now yep well regardless of the
result we will ask away Yi about his
decision to repeat this opening if it
was prep what what the thought process
was there and so is that five situation
that's weird
yeah but he's got Queen g5 coming that's
true wait did you take the h5
the eve one rookie one Chet you can
actually price smack you missed it
Bishop takes h5 stole upon if you took
rook e1 and Queen a one was mate yeah
that was interesting
firoozeh blundered upon way you missed
it will it matter in this game find out
next time just kidding we're not going
to find out next game here on the same
bat-channel
6g c6 okay this has worked out well for
Wei Yi at least if we're considering the
other times he's had this line yeah this
is way better than everything else is
yeah he's gonna go strangle out that h7
pawn there Bishop to elo but that's good
counter play by firoozeh I thought you
take first because now the B files here
right he's gonna flip on onto the the
queenside here I think best though wait
is is down upon right true maui rook c5
oho that hurts
everything's guarded yes nothing on the
clock
and down on the board yeah this is not
good as the last thing that bruiser
could have what it gave by way yeap by
the way after all of us questioning this
opening decision I support from the
opening decision but I agree that he's
playing really I know of course I'm just
saying like he's played phenomenal this
game this has been his best game in some
time never works coming to g5 now I love
it love it
want some more of it defer oh just loose
on time yep you don't see the uprising
surprising himself he's like he just
said did I just lose on time
oh my gosh eighteen minutes dude Wei Yi
is holding his own he's up two games
this is a problem this is a huge problem
that one second increment is huge for
wayy because you know pure bullet match
okay is a monster but with that one
second increment way he is proven that
even if he gets down in time trouble
he's able to hang him there somebody's
got some money on this game a barracks
don't yell at the kid alright it's not
his fault you put way too much money on
him okay he's just a kid alright well
seriously though we are we are excited
about this 9,000 of you here thanks for
being here
we are I'm locked in on I'm just so
excited to see what happens I almost
just want to take five more minutes off
the clock right now so I can get to the
real good I'm an adrenaline junkie as
many of you know wait why is why did you
spend 23 seconds and then we'll be eat
for 23 seconds you can't do that both of
them are spending a ridiculous amount of
time than this move right like I'm I
mean I'm not the best bullet player in
the world but you don't spend so much
time they take c5 as a free pawn
yeah 95 is appalled because it spin and
we saw this tactic earlier and he's and
he's yelling at himself for who should
be kind to yourself he's
what am i doing oh my gosh wait just go
and all the awkward way too many puns
come out right now that's way too many
puns even for this bad dad Joker nice
trap that Queen we've already seen way
to trap fruit clones I see six is
threatened holy bleep er since the
mission be seven just go it's another
reason give it to me if Knight c3 the
flavor of D to it and that's the thing
you do something let your pieces fly you
can even play Knight eight free here if
you're away you just have that's weird
you part with the dark square Bishop
voluntarily take Jesus is he gonna take
up six you might that would be crazy
this pawn is gonna be hard to rally if
this Knight gets to e4 yeah but look at
that I love this the bishops coming to
f5 and it holds e4 and hit C to your
right yeah that was a mistake by way
okay agreed town now population uh yeah
but the back rank is real be careful
here comes Knight d4 that pawn on f6 may
prove to be the thorn you never wanted
there see both playing pretty was yes
especially given the time scramble
situation hey freeze age 6 that means
he's threatening to take B 3 g5 met by H
4 for sure try to open the G file
now the g48 open really for rookie 3
rookie 3 nope
yes yeah I know I'm also speaking in
that we're as a who's deal file open
really for its that are really open for
I'm just like everything's happening so
eyed here but here blacks winning
look at the material
this was definitely miss played by wait
you were right that was an unnecessary
trade taking it for it you're totally
forget for now
rook up for pick up f6 and wait you've
resigns we're gonna be we're gonna be
back to a single game match here just
under 10 minutes
push the pawns just push a baby push
them all push him baby
where's yessir when you need him they're
exactly exactly
before okay you also could have played
rook f6 there because you were
threatening Bishop b5 check but yeah
this is r1 good enough good enough
rook before threatens would be one and
that's why he resigned Wow that's why we
have a one-game match here here we go
here we go Pawar's yes or emotes let's
go emotes mr. Fathead wait you won any
of you over almost every emote I called
for earlier was Purusha if you're
ruining for Wiggy now now's the time to
show it I see some people saying go away
ye so there are definitely some wavy
fries and I don't know who's more tired
firoozeh we just played 13 rounds in the
Turkish league wayy who's playing the
Chinese league and it's really late in
China right now
yeah because actually is it Paris
yesterday do in Paris tomorrow I'm gonna
be a all this chess and no play makes
Dan a dull boy by the end of the week
tell you that there's not up to see him
back to the beginning saying this
reminds me of
Djokovic Federer not quite I'm not gonna
say that it was that it's that epic you
got to get overtime first here yeah look
at those way Yee boats coming out shout
out to the subs Bishop d2 Cruiser there
it is let's go play this Catalan
structure Knight 83 just go for it
no this is just nice for a while it was
efficient 1g2 look at the bishop on CA
this is vintage kappa a good transition
agreed beautiful for white and someone
keep saying s won't sleep of way Winston
died as if as if i ruining heavenly
forouzan oh i like both these players
here
I'm not ruined for any but I've already
gotten what I wanted which is a good
match I you know I'm just I'm just
excited that you know I will say I'm
excited to one of the predictions I said
I felt like this was gonna be closer
than people thought and I thought where
ye would would really and so I'm just
glad that it's showing to be the case
because I think if firoozeh was up
heading into bullet we would have seen a
different thing but okay now he's up
opponent if he wins this we're gonna be
tied with about probably six minutes
left depending on what happens so he's
up upon here Robert this could be
this could be his chance yeah it's a
normal-looking position except black is
missing in a seventh one so for those of
you who may just somehow just be joining
us this has been quite the thriller
recommend you find some time to watch
the full vote of the show because if
this match is tied after this game it'll
be the first time it was tied since it
started way he jumped out to a lead and
has never actually looked back he's been
up the entire match unless we see a
faroush of victory right here so yeah
knowing right now foucha up with pawn in
this ending and he's in a prime position
lays up a ton of time as well he should
I think we're gonna see a tide match for
the first time since it started here in
just a few moments yep this is looking
good for him look at the weak points for
black II 6 is now a target B for good
move Oh g3 is not hanging as an e6 but
is hanging but e 6 is hanging in return
yeah you don't want to take that guy oh
I was wrong I think that was a mistake
here comes the other hook to c6 and the
king can get out Jiwon from g7 g may go
for it but wait but there's no way it
works firuze is gonna be able to trade
this out here ok 6 and then 37 that's
how ok 6 first and rookie 7 only wants
the rook away and then you can take yeah
he finds it no fur is gonna get this one
he's hanging yeah but you got the two
passers yeah they're 2 and oh that's too
much give me house or give me death here
rook on h6
okay 6 remember before I think wrong
trying to make them think my bikes
broken York f5 kingi to kicking g4
oh you get him stuck yeah I'm Anand over
a giri paris grand chest or bring it up
baby
rook f5 worked the King shake what your
mama gave ya this is gonna win we're
gonna have a tight match cutting the
King off but not necessary his rook b3
was a good move now you just need to
bring the King up oh that's huge e baby
just blew it
rookie 4 oh he's freaking out oh no what
did I do
what are you saying that you're now
speaking everything I can't read your
lips it usually Farsi
I'm freaking out five minutes 5 minutes
and he's still down - gay a game yeah he
had that one just I mean that was just a
free man my god dude dad was nuts okay
blow that yeah - you just King h3 kimchi
for right he had the right idea when he
tried to get fancy by cutting on it was
no reason to cut off the king and then
he couldn't believe his own eyes
yeah that was a big mistake maybe it
wasn't winning to begin with but that
clearly made it easier for Wiggy and now
Bishop f6 now play Emily nice five you
forcing it watch out plain just okay
Bishop d7 I was gonna say rookie a first
for the that that was that should
really I mean I know we're all in the
university here but that was really that
that was the most important hold there
of the I mean if you get all the time
off the clock and firuze you doesn't win
this one it might be over yeah that's
very true
I know that's about as Captain Obvious
is saying in order to be good at Bullock
you have to play fast and make good
moves but that's what I'm saying you
know we're going full yogi berra real
greco here if Purusha wants to win this
game he needs to play fast and make good
moves and you know out plays opponent
and make sure these more pieces left the
end and then maybe get checkmate or
resign or read them on time those are
all the ways to win this game
just checking we're on the same page
right now I like blacks position but it
may not last 91 is a very good move trio
what was blacks best piece and now 93
just watch out for f3 though okay he
guards it yep you're right so c5 here
you have to play c5 at some point yeah
over the night but still as she says
this night is gonna get back in wait now
that he's guarded f3 okay Bishop c4 can
just be met by f4 or night at for all
you put it on d5 if you like it then you
put a knight on it oh look at you with
the Queen Bey references before could
undermine the night I don't like taking
on c5 who's ever D takes even my
Brooklyn da guess
knew actually I see great move I really
like them patience patience whoa okay
Knight d5 hit a three hit c3 and then
throw in night 83 to C for 8.4 watch out
finna back
I like a 4 B 5 Robert I told you if I
liked it I was gonna put my knight on
oh no a 4 B 5 undermined the squire and
put a knight there what nobody ate 493
to c4 that was his point okay but he
still has the idea so d5 now five comes
first Knight has to retreat and then d5
yeah
no this looks good for firuze away yi
two and a half minutes left what is
happening here what is the deal we know
ferocious aware of the clock as much as
anybody who's made three go for the meat
whoa you gotta go for the made for ones
you're running out of time knight c6 now
yeah why did the treating move he's
trying to play too solidly this is
turning around if way he wins this game
it's over oh my gosh look at this
position
Oh I mean c5 King g7 is he gonna make it
draw if he makes it draw no wait he
wants more he smells the match he smells
blood this could be it right here
I think well yeah if you win he's got
rook h1 coming next and it's gonna win
oh my god he found it oh my gosh he's a
beast he's up a piece he's okay the
trade is happening but the King has just
done two minutes if way you wins this
game it's not gonna be a comeback Queen
d8 we need to be seven that's all for
rookie aid comes next
Grisi five no okay he went c4 nevermind
there was a nine c7 that we both we both
missed it but it didn't matter because
he's still working it working it with no
diggity here wait he is supposed to
punch his ticket to the finals ferocious
freaking out nights are tricky though or
there's not even this game might also
eclipse the time limit there's only a
minute look he's drawn scheme quickly
and win the last game but he's losing
this position so if you control this
game yeah before the time runs out the
problem is he uh that's it
it's the way he does it with style he
made that look way too easy
oh no you did I can't believe you just
did that
hey what can we just did that it's not
the first time normal would be the last
because I think way ye
is going to give us way too many
opportunities for puns in the finals
because we are way way shocked here the
Kings haven't played a mouse lip or a
troll move you'll never know if he could
win in the next light you know he's
aware that he won he gives us a smile
for the first time ever in his life
maybe I don't know he smiles Perugia
freaking out he knows it's over and we
have an absolute shocker here with wayy
beating again he's the 1 seed so he
would maybe say but even as he told us
Robert
he really considered himself an underdog
in this match he knew he had to prove it
but firoozeh two-slit honestly he went
way too many games go in the blitz
portion to give himself a real bullet
comeback chance that was totally an
overwhelming advantage need wait he
escaped in that game o M Jesus naps yes
the hype is real the match is over Wei
Yi will play Jefferies young in the
juniors beat Chess Championship final
his dream of getting back to the speech
has chanted where we invited him last
year kind of feels bad man now that I
say it but hey if you didn't want to be
invited to the juniors PGA Championship
don't be the number one rated junior in
the world invites be worse in chess yeah
ok firoozeh is kind of on full tilt here
I think that way e wins this last one in
style here he takes on a two mates on c2
we have we have a winner
we have interviews in just a few moments
we have our answer Wei Yi proves that
the bullet portion will not be a run
over even for one of the world's most
elite at the time control poor ollie
resident he just crossed his 2,700 but
he does not punch his ticket to the
finals where we knew we wanted it Robert
I don't know what else to say chat don't
go anywhere
we still have interviews ahead and we
robbed and I will try to wrap this one
up and make sense of what was definitely
one of the most thrilling speech s
matches we've ever had interviews when
we return we'll be right back
[Music]
and what was one of the most thrilling
matches Robin and I have ever had the
pleasure of being a part of I just want
to thank both of you guys first ali reza
and we thank you guys for what was the
one of the best matches we've ever seen
thank you both
all the reza can you hear us he took off
his headphones so i'm not sure
wait you can you hear us okay well first
Ali Reza would give you a huge
congratulations you cross 2,700 today so
hard too hard to think of it as a bad
day even though you've lost this match
but tell everybody if you could please
what you feel the difference was in this
match we know you really wanted to make
it to the final where do you feel the
the game-changing moments were in terms
of why you're not moving on to the
finals lots of good positions but he
defended very well so well the good news
is you still have four or five more
years playing in this event this is
where Yi's last chances it's you and
you're given that he's 20 years old and
you're 16 but I'm now gonna move to wayy
and just say congratulations and what do
you think you need to do to win your
match versus Geoffrey Zhang in the
championship as Usha integrations try to
play games sounds good yeah I I really
don't want to keep you guys long wayy we
know you have a huge event starting
tomorrow and you've really really helped
us out making this schedule work up to
almost 2:00 in the morning there so
we're gonna we're gonna let you get some
rest ali reza i again i know this didn't
work out the way you wanted it to but
you've got a huge fan base here on chest
comm you gave us one of the most
thrilling series of performances in this
event your your victories
Sam Savion just the fact that you barely
didn't get this one again thank you so
much for for the interview and for your
time here and we'll definitely see you
next year
thank you all right bye guys we're gonna
up we're gonna let them go now we we
know both these guys it's late for them
and they made an exception to kind of
stay with us so thank you to them sorry
for the short interviews chat I know we
normally give you more questions but um
plenty more where all the reza came from
and wayy as you see Robert he's in the
finals against Jeffrey Zhang let's go
yeah I'm super excited for that matchup
and honestly it might be changing my
tune here Jeffrey had a tough match
against Benjamin clad aura both these
players are over 2,700 Jeffrey's in the
middle of the Beale tournament trying to
win that open and way he has a big event
starting tomorrow and so he's you know
he's a force I did not expect him to
defeat ali riza firoozeh but he was so
steady it is hard to beat that guy and I
think that Jeffrey will find similar
frustrations but I think that matches a
toss-up to me I know smarter chess
well dive into the statistics and figure
that predictions out but that is a total
toss-up I know as a cop-out but I am so
uncertain about who should be favored
than that right well I'm right there
with you I don't know I told you off the
record before we started this match I
feel like Jeffrey has been overlooked a
lot because of this looming Ollie
resevoir sway you matchup on the left
side of the bracket we've kind of looked
at whoever wins this will win the whole
thing and maybe that'll prove true maybe
wayy will be the favorite but but yeah I
think Jeffrey will probably have more
fans in the chat rooting him on given
that he plays a lot on chess comm god
I've got a very big following so it'll
be super exciting to see what I do know
is regardless of who wins I now know
that we can officially announce the date
the final for the junior speeches
championship will be on August 3rd so
that is not more than five days away
that's I guess the one piece of good
news for fans who were rooting for Olly
Reza I leave as I had won the finals
probably would not have been until
August 11th or 12 so given these players
schedules we are we are now officially
able to confirm that we will have the
championship and figure out who's moving
on to the main SEC bracket in just a few
days Robert yeah I think no matter who
is that the loser has a good chance of
trying to qualify through that qualifier
for the SEC so you know for player like
ali riza furusho you can have his head
hung high he just crossed 2700 classical
chest yeah top of his game and he still
has a chance to qualify nonetheless I
congratulation to him huge congrats to
ye that was a really impressive
performance and Danny congrats to you
for putting up with me for yeah right
you know that that you know that all the
congratulations and thank you goes your
way the pleasure is mine when you put up
with me mr. house but congratulations to
you for punching your card into the Isle
of Man feeding grant Swiss so that's
gonna be pretty exciting let's remind
everybody one more time what the
schedule is coming up while we have you
we've got Paris wrapping and blitz
commentary I will be on the mic tomorrow
I believe joined by Grand Master Eric
Hanson so hope to see you there we've
obviously got the full schedule covering
the Blitz after the rest day on July
30th and now we know that with a very
small break on August 2nd the
championship will be on August 3rd so
juniors features championship coming
your way I don't even know what else to
say besides really appreciate everybody
who's been here all the mods all of our
subscribers all the members in chest TV
chat a whole lot of them today I feel
like just all the love it's Sunday
Robert you know can't we all just have a
great day today I mean we had a great
start to the day at least for you surely
you got ready for this match with family
yep totally true so all right well stick
around for creeks or and Fisher random
because one of the biggest things going
on every Sunday has been the world
Fisher random Chess Championship
qualifiers we've been doing this for a
few months but the heat is really really
going up now as grandmasters are trying
to compete to join what we're gonna
unofficially calling the World Cup
knockout stage Robert we're only 120
players will be competing out of
everybody to try to qualified left
including a number of very very strong
grandmasters we seated there guys likes
Fiddler's guys like Wesley so big big
names have been seeded into the World
Cup stage to try to get to Oslo and
away so right after we get off the air
Creek or we'll be taking over the call
for the Fisher random Chess Championship
qualifier and hope you guys stick around
for that Robert I'd say something even
more awkward than I already have about
how much I love you but I'm not afraid
to show my feelings on air so I'm just
gonna let you go have a good Sunday
there you know I might have to go play
in this qualifier now that you mention
it but good because I'm hungry I'm
hungry for more chests thank you to
everybody who tuned in we've stayed with
us who watched wayy philosophy great
victory over other ways of perugia and
who will continue to see it DJ sec come
to close with that match between
Geoffrey Zhang and Wei Yi next week
not everybody be going for this like
sama Roxy bind because it's not a
Sicilian or a black so the c-pawn weight
as a free piece wait is it Queen TG for
free piece what am I missing
oh you're just like he just went what
did I do
coz c5 doesn't win a piece he just
missed I think he thought c5 was gonna
win it back but it allows Knight b5 with
tempo I think he thought his vision one
seed protected is not energy for
[Music]
you